Rồi buổi hôm nay chúng ta sẽ tổng kết
toàn bộ nội dung chúng ta đã học trong
cả cái khóa này. Mình sẽ chia sẻ cho các
bạn một vài những cái tài liệu và một
vài những nguồn học để sau này nếu các
bạn trong tương lai các bạn muốn ôn lại
kiến thức cũng như là các bạn muốn học
những kiến thức mới thì các bạn sẽ học ở
đâu?
Đầu tiên thì mình sẽ nói về ờ cái nguồn
để chúng ta ôn lại kiến thức. Thế thì à
cái slide của lớp chúng ta thì nó dài
phải khoảng hơn trang. Cái slide này ấ
thì nếu mà các bạn dùng thì khi mà các
bạn mới học lần đầu thì nó ok mới chúng
ta mới học lần đầu chúng ta chưa biết gì
cả. Chúng ta sẽ cần phải có những cái
tài liệu chi tiết. Thế nhưng mà khi mà
các bạn đã học qua kiến thức một lần rồi
thì các bạn sẽ cần những cái tài liệu nó
ngắn gọn nó xúc tích hơn để sau này khi
mà khi các bạn muốn tổng tổng kết hệ
thống hóa kiến thức này hoặc là các bạn
muốn ôn tập để các bạn chuẩn bị cho
phỏng vấn xin việc chẳng hạn thì các bạn
sẽ có những cái tài liệu khác nó phù hợp
hơn. Thế hôm nay mình sẽ chia sẻ cho các
bạn ba cái [hắng giọng]
ba cái bản treit khác nhau mà mình
thường hay dùng để mình ngày xưa đến khi
mà mình ôn tập kiến thức để mình đi
phỏng vấn chẳng hạn thì mình hay dùng
những cái tài liệu này. Nó rất là ngắn
gọn và nó cũng rất là hữu ích. À sau
buổi này thì mình sẽ share tất cả những
tài liệu này lên tất cả những cái tài
liệu mà mình share cho các bạn trong
buổi hôm nay. Sau buổi này mình sẽ up
lên trên Google Drive các bạn nhá. Sau
này các bạn chỉ các bạn vào đây các bạn
lấy thôi. Được chưa? Đầu tiên
cái bản trit đầu tiên mình muốn chia sẻ
bạn đó là cái bản của cái bản của Đọc
Stanford. Cái bản này nó rất là nổi
tiếng. Đây mình cho các bạn nhá. Cái bản
này nó có cả phiên bản offline và bản
online. Các bạn dùng phiên bản nào cũng
được.
Đầu tiên nhá.
Đây các bạn nhá. Đầu tiên là đầu tiên là
cái bản chit của đại học Stanford nó như
này. Các bạn chờ một xíu
đâu ấy nhỉ?
Bạn chờ mình một xíu nha.
À đây rồi
nhá. mình gửi cho bạn cái link này.
Đây thì vẫn luôn là một trong số những
cái những cái nguồn ờ chit số 1 mà mình
vẫn luôn recommend cho các bạn học viên
của mình và kể cả những bạn không phải
học viên của mình các bạn mà hỏi tài
liệu để ôn tập thì mình vẫn luôn chỉ cho
các bạn ấy cái nguồn tài nguyên này. À
mình nói qua một chút
đây là [hắng giọng]
đây là cái trang web cá nhân của đây là
cái trang web cá nhân của của
hai anh em sinh đôi. Hai anh này thì
ngày xưa trong những cái à ngày xưa thì
họ làm trợ giảng cho các cái ờ khóa học
về AI, về machine và về deeping của đạp
Stanford. Năm ngoái thì họ bắt đầu họ
lên làm giảng viên chính. Hai anh em
phải là hai anh em sinh đôi. Mọi người
làm ở một người học ở Stapford, một
người học ở MIT.
Ờ
các bạn kéo xuống dưới một chút các bạn
thấy ở cái phần camion này chúng ta có
ba cái bản tretit. Một bản cho khóa
CS221 cái khóa Vai AI tổng quát. Một bản
cho CS229 là cái khóa về machining và
một bản cho CS230 là khóa về deing.
Ngoài ra thì nó còn có ở dưới nó còn có
một cái vài cái trit bổ trợ nữa. Ví dụ
các bạn quan tâm về cái phần toán cơ bản
chẳng hạn thì các bạn sẽ có một cái chit
về s và thống kê. Thế bây giờ mình sẽ đi
qua một chút về cái chiit quản nhất của
chúng ta. Hôm nay chúng ta là khóa về
machining nên chúng ta sẽ chú chúng ta
sẽ tập tập trung vào cái bản chit dành
cho khóa CS29. Bạn nào học cái khóa sau
chẳng hạn thì các bạn sẽ tập trung vào
cái bản dành cho CS230. Được chưa? Thế
thì với cái bản chit này, mỗi bản chit
các bạn sẽ đều có hai option. Một là các
bạn download file PDF về và hai các bạn
xem bản web.
Thì dù là bản PDF hay là bản web ấ các
bạn sẽ có đều sẽ có rất nhiều ngôn ngữ
khác nhau. Ví dụ về bản web nhá. Ví dụ
bản web nhá.
Các bạn có thể chọn ngôn ngữ ở đây và có
cả tiếng Việt. Được chưa? Tiếng Việt
này. Tiếng Việt này. Được chưa? Đấy.
Được chưa? Tiếng Việt. Hoặc là các bạn
dùng bản các bạn dùng bản PDS nó cũng có
nó cũng có đủ các loại ngôn ngữ khác
nhau. Nó không đủ tất cả các ngữ trên
thế giới nhưng mà trong các ngôn ngữ nó
có tiếng Việt. Đây các bạn nhìn nhá. Đây
này nó có tiếng Việt này. Vi này tiếng
Việt được chưa? Các bạn có thể download
cái bản tiếng Việt về các bạn đọc được.
Các bạn đừng có ke quá nhiều về cái việc
là cái này nó đã 6 năm trước.
Vấn đề 6 năm hay là 10 năm trước thì nó
cũng không có nó cũng không phải là đây
các bạn có cái super chit về machine
này. Đấy các bạn click vào các bạn sẽ
thấy là đây bản trit đ bằng tiếng Việt.
Với những cái môn học mang tính chất nền
tảng như thế này thì 6 năm hay là 10 năm
trước nó không quan trọng tại vì là bao
nhiêu năm trước thì nó vẫn thế. Ví dụ
các bạn học những cái khóa về LR chẳng
hạn những cái khóa về mô hình ngôn ngữ
lớn thì nó cần phải có cái tính cập
nhật. Chứ còn những cái môn về machining
haying này thì 6 năm hay 10 năm trước
cũng chả vấn đề. Tại vì là bao nhiêu năm
rồi nó vẫn nh vẫn vẫn là kiến thức đấy
thôi. Giống kiểu các bạn học cộng trừ
nhân chia hay là bảng cử trương cũng thế
thôi đúng không? Bảng cử trương thì có
bao nhiêu năm nữa thì nó vẫn cứ như thế
thôi. Thì đây nó cũng như vậy. Được
chưa?
Như đây khi mà các bạn vào cái chi tiết
cái khóa CS29 này nhá. Vào lại nhá các
bạn vào chi tiết cái khóa CS29 này. Các
bạn sẽ thấy là nó break ra thành là phần
là liên quan đến supervning, un learning
này, deep learning một chút. Tại vì sao
nó có deep learning? Tại vì về mặt bản
chất thì deeping nó cũng là một cái mảng
con của machining mà đúng không? Cho nên
là đây nó có một chút mà tất nhiên là
cái phần bí deeping này nó sẽ không có
chuyên sâu bằng bằng cái chit dành riêng
cho deing của khóa CS29. Tức là nó có
một cái phần nhỏ nhưng mà nó không có nó
chỉ tổng rất là tổng quát thôi. Thế và
ngoài ra các bạn sẽ có thêm một cái mùng
nữa là tip rất là hữu ích.
Thế bây giờ để mình chúng ta xem cái bản
PDF đi nhá. Nhìn bản PDF nhá. Được
không? Cái bản PDF thì bây giờ xem là có
cái nào zoom nhỉ? Không cái nào zoom
thôi làm sao download về.
nhá.
Thật ra thì thật ra thì mình à
mình recommend các bạn là các bạn nên a
nếu mà các bạn có thể ấy thì các bạn nên
đọc ba cái bản tiếng Anh. Tại vì cái bản
tiếng Việt này nhiều chỗ nó dịch nó cũng
không phải là dịch sai đâu nhưng mà tại
vì tiếng Việt mình nó
ờ có nhiều chỗ nó nếu mà dịch tiếng Việt
thì nghe nó nghe nó hơi nghe nó hơi bị
nghe nó hơi bị bị tù một chút. Nếu các
bạn xem nếu các bạn có thể đọc được
tiếng Anh thì mình recommend các bạn là
các bạn nên đọc ở tiếng Anh thì nó sẽ ok
hơn. Và ngoài ra thì có rất nhiều cái
thuần ngữ mà các bạn mà cố diệt tiếng
Việt ấy thì nghe nó nghe nó không có
được thuận tai cho lắm. Thế đây mình sẽ
đ bản tiếng Anh nhá.
Nhưng mà đến đoạn nào cần mình vẫn sẽ
dấy cho các bạn thôi nhá. Các bạn đọc
được tiếng Anh thì tốt, còn không thì
các bạn không đọc được tiếng Anh thì các
bạn hãy đọc ở tiếng Việt nhá.
Ví dụ đây bản tiếng Anh như này đúng
không? Nó bao gồm thấy bốn cái phần
chính này. Supervise này, unvise này,
deep learning với cả đây tip and thêm
một cái phần nữa là refresher. Cái phần
refacer này nó sẽ bổ trợ cho bạn những
cái kiến thức cơ bản quan trọng nhất về
xác suất thống kê tại số tuyến tính để
giải tích. Đây nó sắp rất thống kê ở
trên này đại số tuyến tính giải thích ở
dưới này nó kiến thức cơ bản thôi được
chưa th đi qua một chút đây các bạn đ về
phần super learning này được chưa dới
hiệu super learning nó là cái gì hai bài
toán cơ bản trong super là regression
với cả classification đúng không đấy ở
dưới là chúng ta có một vài những cái
hàm loss phổ biến này đúng không một vài
hàm los phổ biến này được chưa
nó sẽ có một phần các bạn th sẽ có một
vài phần các bạn thấy thấy nó hơi lạ một
chút. Ví dụ cái phần liên quan đến liên
quan đến cái phần liên quan đến
likelihood này. Tiếp mình sẽ nói thêm
cái phần này. Đây là cái phần mà bạn nào
mà các bạn học những cái chương trình
đào tạo truyền thống trên các trường đại
học ấy 4 năm hoặc 5 năm ấy thì các bạn
sẽ cần phải đi khá là sâu vào những cái
phần này. Thế nhưng mà trong khóa chúng
ta để cho giảm để giảm cái độ khó thì
mình bỏ qua hết cái đoạn này. Bình
thường nếu các bạn học những chương
trình truyền thống ví dụ các bạn học
trên Bách Khoa hoặc là bư chính viễn
thông ở trong miền Bắc hoặc là miền Nam
những cái trường đại học công nghệ thông
tin trong đấy chẳng hạn thì các bạn sẽ
phải học những cái thứ nó sâu hơn những
cái gì chúng ta học trong khóa này được
chưa? Chúng ta sẽ học nặng về toán hơn.
Đấy. Thế ở dưới các bạn thấy chúng ta có
tiếp những cái mô hình này đúng không?
Mô hình tuyến tính này được chưa? Mô
hình tuyến tính này rồi đi sâu hơn vào
cái hàm đây cái hàm sig dành cho mô hình
logistic reation đúng không? Đây hàm
sigmo này. Được chưa?
Hàm sigmo thì nó có cái đặc điểm là nó
sẽ ánh xạ cái input đồ vào ra cái output
đồ ra luôn luôn làm trong khoảng từ 0
đến 1. Được chưa? Còn cái hàm shop là
cái hàm chúng ta dùng trong trường hợp
chúng ta có nhiều hơn hai class. Được
chưa? Nếu chỉ có hai class thôi thì các
bạn có cái số điểm này đúng không? Ví dụ
là 0,65 chẳng hạn thì nếu chúng ta quý
ước là 0,65 cho class số 1 thì 0,35 sẽ
cho class số 0. Nhưng mà khi chúng ta có
nhiều ấn ha class chúng ta sẽ cần phải
dùng hàm shop max này để chúng ta làm
sao chúng ta ánh sạ cái
dự đoán của mô hình cái số điểm mô hình
đã dành cho từng class dành một cái giải
điểm nằm trong khoảng từ 0 đến 1 và tổng
của các cái điểm này đều bằng 1 được
chưa cái hào sắc này các bạn sẽ lại học
lại khi các bạn học về deep learning thì
deing chúng ta sẽ đi dùng show chúng ta
sẽ đề cập hàm số này trong cái hàm los
người ta gọi là cross entryp los nào các
bạn học khóa sau chúng ta sẽ đi sâu lại
về chúng ta sẽ lại gặp lại cái học l này
một lần nữa.
Tiếp theo tiếp theo thì chúng ta có một
vài những cái phân bố phân phối phổ biến
đúng phân phối B các bạn đã các học mô
số thống kê rồi các bạn không còn sa lại
gì về cái phân phối này đúng không B
nully này Gion này phân phối Poison này
phân phối hình học được chưa phần này
thì chúng ta học theo hướng ứng dụng
chúng ta sẽ ít phải để ý hơn bạn nào như
mình nói bạn nào các bạn học theo chương
trình đào tạo dạ chính quy các bạn sẽ
cần phải nắm được những cái này được
chưa support vector machine được chưa
một cái tán rất là thú vị trong
machining được chưa bạn nào các bạn học
trong chương trình đọt đ truyền thống
các bạn sẽ bảo về cerner. Cerner là gọi
là cur trick. Đây là một cái kiến thức
rất là quan trọng trong support machine.
Thế nhưng mà again cái khóa này chúng ta
chúng ta hướng đến là sau bạn đi làm.
Thế nên là chúng ta lược bỏ những cái
phần phức tạp này. Được chưa? Thế còn
cái gì nữa? Nive tán rất là cơ bản. Tán
này nó trong quá trình trên th học lý
thuyết chúng ta nó nói qua một chút về
nó đúng không? Đây là thuật toán mà
chúng ta sẽ giả sử rằng là tất cả các
cái feature của chúng ta nó đ nó độc lập
với nhau đúng không? Đây là cái giải
thết mà trong thực tế nó sẽ ít khi gặp.
Đấy nhưng mà đây cũng là một trong số
những toán rất là cơ bản trong machining
nhưng mà trong tế chúng ta ít khi chúng
ta áp dụng được. Tại vì là cái việc mà
các cái feature nó hoàn toàn nó không
liên quan, không ảnh hưởng độc lập với
nhau trong thực tế nó rất hiếm xảy ra.
Ví dụ trong cái bộ rượu về diabetes
chúng ta chẳng hạn chúng ta có những cái
đặc điểm về tuổi, về giới tính về cái
chỉ số glucozơ hoặc là BM chẳng hạn thì
cái việc mà chúng ta giả sử là dựa chúng
nó chả có mối quan hệ gì với nhau nó
không nó là độc lập với nhau nó rất là
rất là không thực tế đúng không?
Tiếp ở dưới người ta nói về
dựa về dựa đến cây đấy đúng không?
Random forest này đúng không? Cái hôm
chúng ta học lý thuyết mình nói các bạn
là chúng ta ờ trong machining nó có một
cái họ các cái thuật toán gọi là
learning đúng không? Là nó dựa theo cái
việc là chúng ta sẽ kết hợp nhiều mô
hình yếu để thành một cái mô hình mạnh
hơn đúng không? Ví dụ như là random for
chúng ta kết hợp chúng ta kết hợp nhiều
discient lại để chúng ta được một cái mô
hình nó có khả năng dự đoán tốt hơn đúng
không? Thế thì trong các cái unble
learning này nó có nó có ba cái nhánh
chính gọi là backing, boosting với
stacking. Tí nữa thì mình sẽ hôm nọ mình
đã nói các bạn qua rồi mà tí nữa trong
một cái chi tiết nữa thì sẽ chỉ đi sâu
hơn mình sẽ nói lại một lần nữa là
backing boosting và stacking nó khác
nhau như thế nào. Được chưa? Nhưng mà ý
tưởng của chúng đều là gì? Đều là dựa
trên việc là kết hợp khả năng của nhiều
mô hình để tăng kết quả dự đoán cuối
cùng. Được chưa? Chúng ta nói về các cái
thậ toán khác ví dụ đây là non chúng ta
nói về các cái non paricorism
những cái thuật toán machining mà không
có tham số. Ví dụ như Kis Nable vì nó
không có tham số nên các bạn thấy là quá
trình huấn luyện nó nó chả làm cái gì cả
đúng không? Cây n stable quá trình huấn
luyện là hoàn toàn toàn chả có cái gì.
Mọi cái ánh năng là đẩy về quá trình
infent quá trình suy luận đúng không?
Quá trình huấn luyện là không có được
chưa? Nên là không có huấn luyện nó cũng
không có tham số luôn đúng không? Cái số
k ấy thì người ta không gọi nó là tham
số, người ta gọi nó là siêu tâm số. Tham
số với siêu tham số nó khác nhau nào?
Tham số là cái thứ thuộc về nội tại của
mô hình. Nó sẽ được update trong quá
trình huấn luyện. Thế còn siêu hàm số là
những cái giá trị mà các bạn nó nằm ở
bên ngoài mô hình mà chúng ta sẽ là
chúng ta phải chỉ ra cái giá trị này
trước khi chúng ta bắt đầu quá trình
chúng ta huấn luyện. Ví dụ cái số k này
là chúng ta phải tự chọn chứ làm gì có
anh chọn chúng ta đâu đúng không? K chọn
bằng 3 = 4 = 5 do các bạn chọn được
chưa?
Rồi ok đây là phần liên quan đến superv
rồi lại đến uns ở đây ăn superv như mình
nói trong buổi học lý thuyết rồi superv
thì trong thực tế các bạn sẽ ít dùng hơn
nó sẽ khó áp dụng hơn khó áp dụng hơn ít
dùng hơn là tại vì là nó không có nhãn
nó không có nhãn thì rất là khó để chúng
ta có thể giải thích được cái ý nghĩa
của từng cái từng cái cụm đúng không ví
dụ chúng ta nói về clustering chẳng hạn
đúng không nói về clustering đấy cây min
clustering này đúng không
hoặc là hier clustering. Hych of
clustering thì chúng ta sẽ phân cụm theo
kiểu phân tầng. Ví dụ lúc đầu chúng ta
sẽ phân thành ba cụm, sau đó mỗi một cụm
chúng ta lại phân ra là ba cụm con tiếp
đúng không?
Tương tự như là hyc clusting, chúng ta
cũng sẽ có hyc classification theo bài
toán phân loại theo kiểu tầng đúng
không? Tầng đầu tiên chúng ta phân thành
ba nhóm, tầng sau chúng ta thành phân
thành mỗi nhóm này phân thành ba nhóm
con chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy được chưa?
Thế thì trong bài toán clustering ấ thì
thật ra là người ta vẫn có cái magic để
người ta đánh giá mặc dù nó là bài toán
unsprovide. Mặc dù là answer by mặc dù
là không có rượu và đánh nhãn nhưng mà
người ta người ta vẫn có cách để người
ta có thể đánh giá cái performance của
mô hình. Ví dụ có một cái magic rất là
phổ biến như thế này. Cái magic này thì
nó đánh giá bằng cách nào? Các bạn nhìn
công thức nó đây bằng B - A chia cho max
của AB. B với A là cái gì các bạn? Nhìn
đây. A nó là cái khoảng cách trung bình
giữa các cái điểm trong cùng một
cluster. Thế còn B là cái khoảng cách
trung bình của các cái điểm thuộc
cluster này đến clustter kia. Đúng
không? Thì rõ ràng là nếu mà cái mô hình
nó phân nó phân cụm tốt ấy thì a nó sẽ
rất là bé và b nó sẽ rất là lớn đúng
không? A là khoảng cách khoảng cách giữa
điểm cho cùng cluster mà. Thì nếu các
cái điểm thuộc cùng cluster nó tương
đồng nhau thì khoảng cách nó sẽ bé đúng
không? Thế còn các cái điểm thuộc
cluster này đến điểm thuộc cluster kia
nó sẽ khác nhau nhiều thì B nó sẽ lớn
đúng không? Thế nên là cái matric này ấy
cái tử số nó càng lớn thì càng tốt đúng
không? Tử số lớn có nghĩa là B thì lớn
mà A thì bé. Được chưa? Nên là cái cái
magic này nó càng lớn thì mô hình nó
càng tốt. Được chưa? Tất nhiên cái giá
trị đó nó cũng nằm trong khoảng từ 0 đến
1 thôi. Tại vì người ta có cái phần mẫu
số này rồi. Mẫu số là max của a với b
được chưa?
Thế nhìn chung thì các cái toán về nó sẽ
ít áp dụng và không phải ít áp dụng mà
khó áp dụng và nó ít phổ biến hơn. Được
chưa? Và sau đó chúng ta trong khóa này
chúng ta học một cái toán thứ hai nữa. T
chúng ta học hai độc toán về unv là cin
clustering và hai là PCA đúng không? PCA
dùng để giảm chiều dữ liệu. Giảm chiều
dữ liệu này được chưa?
PCA.
Đấy. Thế sau đó thì chúng ta có một cái
phần nữa là về deep learning mà thôi cái
phần này thì chúng ta chưa học nên là
thôi chúng ta biết như vậy thôi. Về thứ
hai nữa là cái de learning này ấ thì các
bạn xem cái chiit dành riêng về của cái
khóa deing ấ thì nó sẽ ok hơn tại vì nó
sẽ chuyên dâu hơn. Cái chi dành riêng
của này ví dụ mình cho bạn xem thử nhá.
Đây nó nó sẽ đi sâu hơn. Thế còn cái thế
còn trong cái chit này thì nó đi qua một
chút thôi, nói qua một tí. Trong ling
thì trong ling thì người ta có một cái
kiến trúc gọi là new network hay là mạng
neuron. Mạng neuron này nó là cái mô
phỏng của cách mà cái não bộ con người
nó hoạt động các cái neuron nó liên kết
nó kết nối với nhau.
Thì trong mạng neuron thì các cái neuron
nó sẽ xếp thành những cái tầng thành
những cái tầng. Đây các bạn nhìn những
cái tầng này được chưa? Các cái tầng nó
sẽ chịu nghiệm là gì? nó trích suất đặc
trưng từ cái input đầu vào nó trích suất
cho nó tổng hợp rồi nó gửi đến cái tầng
kế tiếp nó giống như cách não bộ chúng
ta hoạt động vậy thôi. Mắt chúng ta nhận
biết cái ảnh phía trước chẳng hạn đúng
không? Sau đó thì cái ảnh này sẽ được
truyền đến cái neuron neuron trước nó
tổng hợp thức nó tổng hợp cái thông tin
nó truyền thành cái neuron tiếp theo cứ
liên tục như vậy thì lúc nó đến não bộ
não bộ nó sẽ xử lý cuối cùng đúng không?
Thế th đấy đấy là cái ý tưởng người ta
đưa
neuron trong não chúng ta thành neuron
nhân tạo trong máy. Được chưa? Thế thì à
cái new network này thật ra nó cũng
không phải là tên của một kiến trúc cụ
thể đâu. Nó không phải như kiểu là
linear reaction hay là logistic
reaction. Tức là nó là tên của cái thán
cụ thể. Thì cái new network này nó không
phải là tên của kiến trúc cụ thể mà nó
là một cái tên gọi chung của các cái
kiến trúc tronging mà người ta xây dựng
người ta dựa trên neuron. Ờ nó giống
kiểu là cái xe ô tô ấy đúng không? Xe ô
tô không phải là tên một cái phương tiện
cụ thể mà nó chỉ là cái tên gọi chung
của của một cái loại phương tiện thôi.
Từ xe ô tô các bạn sẽ có nhiều loại xe
các bạn có xe BMW, các bạn có xe Vinfat,
các bạn có xe Mercedes chẳng hạn. Ví dụ
như vậy thì sau này trong New Network nó
có rất nhiều kiến trúc khác nhau. Ví dụ
là với những cái bài toán làm việc với
ảnh chẳng hạn, với ảnh hoặc là video thì
người ta sẽ có một kiến trúc người ta
gọi là convolutional new network hay là
mạng neuron
tích chập để chúng ta xử lý những cái
bài toán trong mảng thị giá máy tính,
trong mảng computer vision. Thế còn
trong mảng xử lý ngôn ngữ tự nhiên mảng
NLP Nature Lage Processing ấy cái mảng
làm việc với tex ấy văn bản ấy ạ thì
ngày xưa người ta có một kiến trúc rất
là phổ biến người ta gọi là recurent new
network hay là mạng n hồi qu thế nhưng
mà sau này cùng với sự xuất hiện của
transformer các cái mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn
thì bây giờ chủ yếu người ta sẽ dựng
những cái mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn thay vì
người ta sử dụng kiến trúc liên quan đến
recon network
Và nó còn có rất nhiều kiến trúc khác
nữa thì sau này khi mà các bạn đi show
vào cái bảng này các bạn sẽ sẽ tìm hiểu
thêm. Đây các bạn thấy không? Con motion
này recent đây tức rất là cơ bản thôi
các bạn. Sau các bạn xem cái khóa C30 nó
sẽ đi sâu hơn nó đi sâu vào convtion vào
recurrent này được chưa?
Reinforceing này người ta cũng nói một
tí nhưng mà thật ra cái mảng này như
mình nói các bạn trong những cái buổi
đầu tiên chúng ta học về điểm lý thuyết
rồi cái mảng reinforcement learning này
các bạn nhìn chung là các bạn các bạn
thừa thời gian các bạn hãy tìm hiểu, còn
không thì các bạn cũng không tìm hiểu nó
nó cũng chả ảnh hưởng gì đến sự nghiệp
sau này các bạn tại vì là cái bản này
rất là khó xin việc và nó rất ít việc
mặc dù cái ứng dụng nó rất là hay nhưng
mà cái cơ hội về làm nó rất là ít nhá.
Tiếp theo chúng ta có một vài phần liên
quan đến tip magric th tên gọi như vậy
thôi. Th ra nó chỉ là một vài cái cái
kiến thức bổ trợ. Ví dụ là kiến thức về
những cái magic đúng không? Là sao chúng
ta có thể đánh giá một cái mô hình
classification, một cái mô hình
regression đúng không? Chúng ta có những
cái matric gì đúng không các bạn? Cái
ảnh này rất là giống cái ảnh chúng ta
dùng trong khóa của chúng ta đúng không?
Đấy chúng ta có cái confusion magic đúng
không? Một vài tên và những cái magic cơ
bản này được chưa? RC AUC được chưa?
Trong regression chúng ta có cái gì?
Chúng ta có mean square, mean absute,
chúng ta có coefficient of determination
này. Được chưa? Đấy.
Phân chia rượu nào đúng không? Chia
thành ba bộ đúng không? Hoặc là chia
theo kiểu kef cross validation. Được
chưa? K cross validation này. Được chưa?
Regularization chính quy hóa đúng không?
Để làm sao để tránh cho mô hình nó bị
overiting giảm độ phức tạp đúng không?
Chúng có l có ris có elastic này. Được
chưa? Bi variant off chúng ta có học rồi
được chưa?
Rồi và một vài kiến thức toán cơ bản
được chưa? Vài kiến thức toán cơ bản về
xác suất thống kê, về đại số tuyến tính,
về giải tích. Thế đây là cái bản chí
mình rất là ưa thích tại vì nó không có
quá dài. Các bạn nhìn này. Nó chỉ có
16 trang đúng không? So với việc là các
bạn xem các bạn cầm cái slide của bất kỳ
một cái khoa học nào các bạn cầm cái
chiit này nó sẽ gọn nó rất là nhiều. Họ
tổng họ tổng một kiến thức rất là ok.
Mình thấy là họ chất lọc những kiến thức
quan trọng nhất, tổng quát nhất mà các
bạn cần phải nắm được khi các bạn học về
machining. Được chưa? Cái chi tiết này
thì nó được xây dựng dựa trên cái nội
dung của chính cái khóa này luôn. Tất
nhiên là người ta đã tóm lược rồi, người
ta giảm bớt những cái thừa rồi. Tuy
nhiên thì mình vẫn đánh giá là cái chiếc
xe này nó vẫn có khoảng 30 đến 40% nó
cũng khá là hàn lâm. Tại vì là suy cho
cùng đây là cái chiếc được được
chắp bút từ một cái khóa học trong một
cái chương trình đào đoạn chính quy của
đọc Stanford. đúng không? Cái khóa này
là khóa trên trường đại học chứ không
phải khóa ở ngoài. Mà khóa trên trường
đại học thì tất nhiên nó phải có một cái
độ hàn lâm nhất định. Thế thế nên là nó
vẫn có một vài cái phần mà nó sẽ hơi hàn
lâm một chút. Có thể các bạn sẽ nhìn sẽ
hơi khó hiểu. Nhưng về tổng quát thì đây
là một cái ch rất đánh giá rất là tốt.
Ngày xưa hồi mình còn là sinh viên ấy,
mình rất hay dùng chiit này trước khi
mình đi phỏng vấn khoảng 3 4 ngày ấ mình
hay ngồi ôn lại bằng cái bản trit này.
Được chưa?
Rồi và cái bàn này như mình nói có rất
nhiều ngôn ngữ khác nhau. Các bạn đọc
được bằng tiếng Anh thì tốt còn không
các bạn đọc tiếng Việt cũng được mà
tiếng Việt thì nó sẽ có một vài chỗ nghe
nó hơi ngang một chút.
Ok đấy là cái bản chiit đầu tiên. Và nếu
mà các bạn muốn tìm hiểu trước về deep
learning các bạn hoặc là các bạn có thể
xem cái bản set 30 này. Đây 230 là của
deep learning được chưa?
Ok có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào có thắc mắc gì không?
Anh có thắc mắc gì không? Đây nhá. Thì
tí nữa sau cái buổi này mình sẽ chia sẻ
tất cả những chi tiết này mình sẽ up lên
trên Google Drive cho các bạn. Còn không
thì các bạn vào đây các bạn lấy tại vì
đây mình mình cũng download đây mà ra
thôi.
Rồi đây là bản đầu tiên. Bản này thì có
16 trang vẫn hơi dài đúng không? Mình
chia sẻ bạn một vài cái bản khác nó ngắn
hơn nữa. Cái bản thứ hai rất là hay. Cái
bản này thì mình không nhớ là nó từ đâu
mà ra.
Bản thứ hai nó chỉ có sáu trang thôi à
nó chỉ có năm trang thôi. Bản này thì
cũng là bản tập trung nó tóm tắt tóm
lượt những cái kiến thức về machining.
Mình thấy là cái này nó đỡ hàn lâm hơn
một chút. Tuy nhiên thì cái bản này thì
à
nó sẽ có một vài cái chỗ nó nó lược bỏ
hơi hơi sâu. Cái bản này thì cũng ok.
Cũng ok. Các bạn dựa vào đây thì cũng
được. Nó nói về các cái mô hình đúng
không? Về mấy mô hình thế nào gọi là
tuyến tính, thế nào gọi là phi tuyến
đúng không? Thế nào là mô hình có tham
số, mô hình phi tham số. Được chưa?
Thật ra ấy ở đây có một cái mà nó sẽ hơi
bị miss misl một chút. Tức là nó sẽ phân
lại tức là mô hình có tham số và mô hình
phi tham số hoặc là mô hình tuyến tính
và mô hình phi tuyến. Chứ còn parametric
về linear nó không tương đương với nhau.
Viết này người ta sẽ dễ nhầm là gì? Là
pha magic. Còn có cái tên gọi khác là
linear nhưng mà không phải. Được chưa?
Fic là những mô hình có tham số.
Ví dụ như là mô hình linear reaction là
mình có tham số.
Thế còn mô hình phi tham số ví dụ là ờ
kist table là phi tham số được chưa? Thế
còn linear v nó non linear nó nói nó
việc là tuyến tính với cả phi tuyến đúng
không? Tuyến tính ví dụ linear direction
phi tuyến là ví dụ random f chẳng hạn ví
dụ như vậy được chưa? Đấy nói về superv
uns này đúng không? Best and ch off này
đúng không? Ờ nói về các cái hiện tượng
underfitting overfitting đúng không?
Chúng ta nói về chúng ta nói về quadient
de gradient des thì thật ra đây là cái
này nó sẽ nội dung của tức là quen desen
nó là cái kỹ thuật người ta dùng để
người ta có thể tối ưu hóa cái tham số
của mô hình hay là nó áp dụng rất là phổ
biến trong deep learning các cái thán
trong machining thì người ta cũng có thể
dùng cái này ví dụ là trong linear
reaction người ta cũng có thể người ta
optimize mô hình linear re bằng guardian
descent desen nó dựa trên khá nghiệm
guardian guardian là cái gì guardian nó
là phiên bản mở rộng của đạo hàm ngày
xưa các bạn học ngày xưa hồi cấp Ba
chúng ta học đạo hàm là đạo hàm
đạo hàm của hàm bậc 1 đ à x không phải
của hàm bậc 1 mà đạo hàm của hàm một
biến đúng không? Hàm một biến người ta
gọi là đạo hàm nhưng mà hàm hai biến, ba
biến, bốn biến trở lên ấy thì người ta
không gọi đạo hàm người ta gọi là
guardian. Được chưa? Đấy thì đây là cái
ý tưởng dựa vào guardiền để tôi có thể
tối ưu hóa tham số của mô hình làm sao
cho càng ngày mô hình nó càng dự án tốt
hơn. Được chưa?
Rồi các cái thất toán linear reaction
này được chưa?
Rồi chúng ta áp dụng regularization được
chưa? áp dụng reation đúng không? Chúng
ta sẽ có gọi có tên gọi là l hoặc là
reach được chưa? Là L1 đấy. Rich là L2
đấy. Được chưa?
Ờ gì nữa? Chúng ta có logistic
regression được chưa? Logistic
regression này chúng ta có cái gì nữa
nào? Đấy ví dụ các bạn mà học ở trên các
cái chương trình đào tạo chính quy các
bạn sẽ phải học những cái ví dụ là
discment analyst này nhưng mà các bạn đi
làm bạn không cần không cần phải đi vào
cái này được chưa?
Ch toán phi tuyến đúng không? Deci tree,
random forest đều là phi tuyến cả đúng
không? Cây stable cũng là cây bạn
support machine cũng là phi tuyến đúng
không? Cũng là phi tuyến. Cây inable án
nonic đúng không? Nó hoàn toàn nó không
có tham số gì cả. Được chưa?
Đây đâ chúng ta nói thêm về backing với
boosting này. Backing này.
Boosting này. Được chưa? Nó còn thiếu
stacking nữa. Stacking tí mình sẽ cái
chi tiết xí cuối mình sẽ nói một chút.
Đấy. Thì đây là bản chi tiết nó chỉ có
năm trang thôi. Cái bản này thì nó gọn.
Này thì nó gọn
gọn nhưng mà thật ra mình thấy nó cũng
nó gọn thì gọn thật nhưng mà nó cũng
thiếu một vài cái khá là quan trọng. Ví
dụ những cái đề liên quan đến Magic
chẳng hạn nó nó cũng chưa có đầy đủ cho
lắm. Nhưng mà anyway đây cũng là một cái
bảng nó rất là tốt mà khi mà các bạn
muốn ờ tổng hưởng kiến thức chúng ta
trong thời gian ngắn thì các bạn có thể
dùng cái bản này. Được chưa? Đây bản số
2. Bản này tí mình up cho các bạn lên.
Mình cũng không nhớ nó là nguồn từ đâu.
Nhìn không nhớ là nguồn này nó đến từ
đâu. Đây giải đây này.
Tiếp nhá. Nguồn thứ ba. Nguồn thứ ba
nguồn rất là hay. Nguồn này nó sẽ hơi
dài một chút nhưng mà nó
18 trang dài hơn cái bản của STF một
chút. Cái bản này nó rất là hay.
Cái bản này ấ thì người ta
tổng kết nó không giống như hai cái bản
kia mà nó sẽ tổng kết theo cái kiểu là
dựa thành những các cái người ta sẽ phân
chia thành các cái kiến thức dựa trên
các cái câu hỏi phỏng vấn. Đây này ờ cái
gì đây?
Các
bạn dữ c phỏng vấn t là gì? Ví dụ các
bạn người ta sẽ phân chia thành cái
topic này đúng c phỏng vấn này do các
bạn vào xố các bạn vào từng phần nhá
đúng không? Mari chop là cái gì? Và các
bạn cái tài liệu này cũng cái rất là hay
là cái phần chư quân hóa họ làm rất là
tốt. Họ có rất nhiều cái hình vẽ minh
họa để giúp các bạn có thể hiểu cái khái
niệm hiểu kiến thức nó dễ dàng hơn. Được
chưa? Varient này
à đây đúng không? B variant off này đúng
không? Chúng ta có cái gì nữa? Chúng ta
có cái phần liên quan đến đến
imbalance data đúng imbalance tức là khi
mà số lượng sample của số lượng sample
của hai class trong đây là imellent sẽ
nói riêng với bài toán phân loại thôi
đúng không? Khi mà số lượng sample của
hai class nó lệch nhau một ống rất nhiều
ống rất ít hoặc là có nhiều hơn hai
class đúng không? Một cái class nó có
rất nhiều so với những class còn lại thì
đấy là cái dấu hiệu của iment dataset.
Thế thì khi mà set chúng ta sẽ không
dùng accuracy nữa được chưa? Chúng ta sẽ
không dùng mặt qu nữa. Chúng ta sẽ dùng
là vision rec và F1 đúng không? Và đây
chúng ta sẽ nói về các cái phương pháp
để chúng ta có thể giải quyết, chúng ta
có thể khắc phục, chúng ta có thể hạn
chế cái hiện tượng là imance data hoặc
là chúng ta đúng không? Chúng ta th over
sammeling các thứ đúng không? Chúng ta
có thể thay đổi được cái hàm loss khiến
cho cái hàm los nó tập trung hơn và
class được chưa? Thay đổi thuật toán
cũng được đúng không? Đấ
PCA đúng không? Thật toán giảm chiều dữ
liệu PCA.
Đúng không? Giảm chiều dữ liệu.
Tiếp B Serum này đúng không? Các cái mô
hình phân loại các cái bài toán
reversation bao gồm cả ở đây người ta
xếp cả logistic
version thật ra logistic version tức là
tên nó có cái chữ viion nhưng mà nó là
tổ toán dành cho bài toán classification
đúng không? Linear chúng ta học rồi đúng
không? Polynomial học rồi đúng không?
Rich vô gi chẳng qua tôi áp dụng
regation tôi vào thôi đúng không? Đây là
áp dụng L2 này. Đây áp dụng L1 này. Được
chưa? Đấy.
Và cái summary đúng tổng quát chúng ta
được chưa? Requization là gì đúng không?
Chúng ta có L1 hay gọi là lo
gọi là reach đúng không? Kết hợp E1 với
L2 người ta gọi là elastic đúng không?
Đây nói về KF Cross validation này. Được
chưa? V chi tiết về conversion cái này
thì các bạn chú chưa học nên là chúng ta
cũng không có nói nhiều được nhưng mà
nhìn chung đây nó cũng tổng kết cho các
bạn xem là CNN hay là convtion new
network on một ký trúc rất là phổ biến
để chúng ta có thể giải quyết bài toán
trong mảng thị giáp máy tính đây người
ta tổng kết là nó có những loại layer gì
phổ biến được chưa đấy một vài những
kiến trúc CN phổ biến thôi cái này thì
chúng ta chưa học đến nên là mình cũng
không có nói được nhiều được chưa một
vài những kiến trúc phổ biến nổi tiếng
trong lịch sử phát triển của deep
learning đấy đây này unsable learning
đúng không chúng ta có Backing, boosting
với stacking. Backing, boosting và
stacking đúng không? Backing giống kiểu
random fres chúng ta sẽ dùng ca cái mô
hình con chạy song song với nhau. Mỗi mô
hình con sẽ được huấn luyện với một cái
bộ rượu con đúng không? Thay vì huấn
luyện toàn bộ dữ liệu sau chúng ta sẽ
tổng kết kết quả. Nhưng mà đây sẽ tiêu
biểu là random fresh. Boosting thì là
gì? Boosting là chúng ta vẫn dùng k mô
hình như vậy chúng ta sẽ không dùng
chúng nó song song nữa. Chúng ta dùng
tuần tự. Cái mô hình sau. Tất cả cái mô
hình này sẽ đều được huấn luyện với toàn
bộ dữ liệu. Nhưng mà mô hình sau thể
focus nhiều hơn vào cái sample mà cái mô
hình trước nó dự án xa. Được chưa? Đấy
gọi là boosting và đến cuối ta sẽ tổng
hợp kết quả từ tất cả những cái mô hình
này nhau. Cuối cùng là stacking.
Stacking nghĩa gì? Stacking tức chúng ta
sẽ có hai giai đoạn huấn luyện. Giai
đoạn đầu tiên chúng ta sẽ huấn luyện k
mô hình. Thế nhưng mà cái sự khác biệt
của stacking với cả backing boosting là
gì? Đó là nếu mà backing boosting ấy thì
thường các cái mô hình nó cùng một loại.
Ví dụ như là cùng là decision tre chẳng
hạn. Thì trong cái stack nghĩ thì thường
là các cái mô hình con này sẽ thuộc về
những cái loại khác nhau. Để mô hình là
mô hình l
có mô hình này. Mô hình con này là
decision tre mô hình con kia là logistic
reation. Ví dụ như vậy. Do người ta sẽ
cho hết một cái mô hình nữa người ta gọi
là metamod. Cái mô hình này nó sẽ nhận
input đầu vào là cái prediction của
những cái mô hình con kia và nó sẽ làm
sao nó huấn luyện để nó dựa vào cái
input là cái prediction này nó sẽ đưa ra
cái dự đoán của mình. Thế thì đây người
ta gọi là stacking chưa? Backing,
boosting với stacking. Đấy, một cái phần
này liên quan đến deep learning mất rồi.
Trong à code có hàm nào? Có các bạn ạ.
Có các cái thư viện ví dụ các bạn về
boosting các bạn có sẽ x boost nhá. Hôm
nọ mình chị bảo các bạn về các bạn thử
tự tìm hiểu. Đấy, đây này. X boost được
chưa? Boost này đây là tập trung vào
boosting tập trung vào boosting. Thế còn
backing thì trong se lớn nó cũng có nó
nó cũng có nó cũng có backing trong này
nó cũng có ví dụ chúng ta bản thân khi
mà chúng ta dùng random fred thì chúng
ta dùng backing rồi đấy. Được chưa? Nó
có thư viện làm. Tất nhiên chúng ta tự
code thì cũng được thôi nhưng mà tự code
thường nó sẽ không có efficient nó cũng
sẽ không có hiệu quả bằng việc chúng ta
dùng thư viện được chưa?
Chứ còn giá tên là thời bây giờ làm gì
có ai đi code bao giờ đâu đúng không?
thì có ai tự đi code mô hình lại từ đầu
đâu.
Tiếp ở đây nó có thêm một cái file phần
này thì mình cũng nó cũng không liên
quan lắm thì cái phần liên quan đến a
chi sách dành cho cấu trúc rượu và giải
thuật đúng không? Các cái cấu trúc dữ
liệu ví dụ là danh sách này, danh sách
liên kết đơn, danh sách liên kết đôi,
ngăn xếp, hàng đợi thứ vân vân đúng
không? Bảng băng cây đồ thị chư cái này
thì không hẳn là về ấy nhưng mà thôi
không sao. Anyway cũng không bổ dọc thì
bổ ngang. Cái phần dưới này, cái phần
này thì thôi cái này mình thấy không có
quan trọng lắm tại vì cái này nó phụ
thuộc vào mỗi người nữa. Ví dụ như mình
thì chả bao giờ mình phải dành nhiều ra
như này. Mình nhì mình ôn vài ngày thôi
là xong
rồi. Đây là cái chi tiết thứ ba. Đây
mình thấy nó cái điểm mạnh của chi tiết
này là gì? Là nó có cái tính chư quân
hóa rất là mạnh, rất là ok. Rất là nhiều
hình vẽ các thứ này.
Ok. Có bạn nào cô có câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào có thắc mắc gì không?
tiếp nhá. Thì đấy là cái trit
trit thì dùng để ôn tập đúng không? Thì
bây giờ nếu trong tương lai mà các bạn
muốn tìm hiểu những thứ tức là chung
quay chúng ta học về machining rồi sao
các bạn muốn tìm hiểu về defening các
bạn làm thế nào?
Thì thật ra ấy
thật ra thì khi mà các bạn học de
learning ấy các bạn cũng không nhất
thiết là các bạn phải học khóa học của
mình.
Ờ nếu các bạn thấy là các bạn tự học
được thì các bạn hoàn toàn các bạn có
rất là nhiều option. Bây giờ mình sẽ chỉ
bạn option. Đây là những cái khoa học mà
bản thân mình ngày xưa cái hồi mình học
về AI ấy, mình có học những cái khóa học
này.
Đầu tiên mình phải nói là ngày xưa hồi
mình học AI ở tu Monex ấy, ở đâ thuật
monic ấy thì trong trường mình cũng có
những cái môn về machine living có đủ cả
chả thiếu cái gì cả. Nhưng mà thật ra mà
nói thì mình thấy là mình không đánh giá
cao lắm về cái slide cũng như là cái tài
liệu của trường mình. Thể bị là vì là
mình thấy là nó cũng nó không dễ hiểu
thế. Nó không dễ hiểu. Không phải là vì
hồi đấy mình không phải là vì hồi đấy
mình à mình là người mới học mà mình
thấy khó hiểu mà thực sự là cách trình
bày nó khó hiểu thật.
Đây mình cho các bạn xem cái slide của
trường mình ngày xưa. Bạn nào các bạn
thích thì tí nữa các bạn inbox mình mình
share cho các bạn. Nhưng mà cái đạn này
thì thực sự là nó khó đọc lắm nên các
bạn chờ mình một tí nhá. Đây đây nhá. Ví
dụ đây là cái tài đây là phần về disent
chẳng hạn. Đây là ngày xưa mình học là
mình học cái này này đây tu monic này
cái chữ monic trong tiếng Đức nó viết
như này minion được chưa thầy như này
đấy deentry này
đấy nó sẽ nó sẽ phức tạp hơn so với cái
slide của lớp chúng ta tại vì đây là cái
khoa học trên trường đại học nó khác với
khoa học chúng ta thấy không nó sẽ rất
là nặng về toán rất là nặng về toán được
chưa chúng ta chèo về gini thôi ngoài ra
nó còn có là entop nhiều cách khác khác
để chúng ta đánh
cái mức độ khi chúng ta phân chia các
cái nốt đúng không? Đấy.
Rồi rất nhiều thứ đúng không? Rất nhiều
thứ không nhiều toán không?
Nhiều thứ ngoài cái việc nó nhiều toán
thì ngoài ra mình thấy là nó rất là khó
hiểu nữa. Cho đến bây giờ đọc lại nhiều
chỗ mình vẫn chả hiểu.
Đây
cái này là cái phần liên quan đến like
hood. Đây cũng là cái phần mà
ờ khóa đình mình thì không em ạ. Tại vì
bây giờ gần như chả ai dùng nữa rồi.
Cái khóa của mình cái khóa nâng cao. Cái
khóa de mình nâng cao sẽ nói về phần
recurent new network. Thế nhưng mà bây
giờ recurrent new network là rất là ít
khi dùng, rất ít dùng. Họa trăng có dùng
thì người ta sẽ dùng cho liệu dạng time
series chứ còn bây giờ rec lắm. Bây giờ
với cái sự phát triển của LOM rồi thì
người ta sẽ dùng LM chứ người ta không
dùng requent new để sử cái bài toán
trong mảng NLP nữa
nhá. Tiếp về đây nhá.
Các bạn yên tâm những cái gì mình đưa
vào trong K và những thứ mình thấy là nó
dùng nhiều nhất rồi. Những cái gì nó phổ
biến nhất rồi còn những cái gì mình
không đưa vào có nghĩa là nó ít phổ biến
nhá. Đây tài liệu của mình như thế này đ
các bạn không toàn toán đây các bạn nhìn
này. Đây nó như thế này. Đấy nếu các bạn
học trên trường đại học nó sẽ phải cỡ
như này được chưa? như thế này.
Đấy, được chưa? Rất nhiều công thức.
Đúng rồi. Tại vì là tại vì là khi các
bạn học đại học các bạn sẽ phải hiểu sâu
hơn.
Các bạn sẽ hiểu sâu hơn, các bạn sẽ phải
hiểu cái nền tảng vì sao môn hình đựng
sư như vậy đúng không? Mà muốn hiểu sâu
sẽ phải đi vào toán đúng không? Không
phải chỉ có trường này đâu, trường nào
cũng thế thôi. Các bạn thng cái tài liệu
của cái trường ở Việt Nam nó cũng thế
chả khác gì. Các bạn thấy tài liệu của
bên Bách Khoa là bên Trí N thông nó cũng
y chang như vậy.
À các bạn đi phỏng vấn người ta không
hỏi sâu này đâu. Thường ta không hỏi sâu
này tại vì là kể cả người hỏi các bạn ấy
người ta cũng không có người ta cũng
không biết sâu như này. Cái này thì dùng
để cho các bạn hiểu bản chất thôi chứ
còn đi phỏng vấn bạn không đến mức như
này đâu. Nếu cần là mình đã cho vào
trong góc rồi nhưng mà chúng ta sẽ không
cần đến mức đấy. Bản thân mình đi phỏng
vấn cũng chả ra bị hỏi cái mức như này.
Thế được chưa?
Đấy nhưng mà ý mình đang nói các bạn là
nếu các bạn học trong một chương trình
đào tạo chính quy thì nó sẽ cỡ như thế
này. Nó sẽ khó hơn cái khóa của chúng ta
rất là nhiều. Được chưa?
Đấy
ngày xưa hồi ngày xưa hồi mình học ấy
hồi 2015 hồi 2015 2016 mình học cái này
cũng chả hiểu gì cả. Xong mình cũng phải
lên mặt mình à xem cái khoa học khác.
Thì cái nguồn học mà mình rất là
recommend các bạn đó là những cái khoa
học của đại học Stanford.
Bản th cái chiit này.
Bản th cái chiit này cũng từ
cũng từ khóa của đạp Scanford mà ra. Ví
dụ nhá khóa CS229 nhá.
Nhá khóa về machining.
Cái khóa này người ta upload cả video cả
phiên bản đc à cả phiên bản chữ. Các bạn
đọc cái nào cũng được.
Ví dụ những phiên bản trước nhá.
Các bạn muốn học theo kiểu material thì
thì đây
material ở đâu ấ nhỉ?
Xẽ về bản mấy năm trước đi.
đây
ở đâu ấ nhỉ? À cuối thì hiểu cuối thì
phải. Đúng rồi.
Đây nhá. ở cuối cái file này
đấy. Nó có cái a class note này mấy cái
năm cũ nó còn có cả slide nữa. Còn có
slide nữa. Một là các bạn xem ở đây
không là các bạn lên YouTube các bạn gõ
khóa set 29 này.
Đây
cái này thì
nó mới có phiên bản mới hơn là phiên bản
năm 2025.
2025.
À không s bạn 2015 là phiên bản de của
lớp deep learning.
À đây
ngày xưa hồi mình học là ngày xưa mình
học cái phiên bản cũ hơn cơ tại vì hồi
mình học là 2015 2016 mình học phiên bản
cũ hơn cơ đấy nhưng mà học th này rất là
tốt thế nhưng mà các bạn nhưng mà tại vì
chúng ta học xong machining rồi cái này
sẽ không có hữu ý lắm nhưng mà ví dụ các
bạn muốn hỏi về deep learning nhá de
learing thì đây deep learning thì nó sẽ
có ba khóa xem họ sẽ có ba khóa một là
cái khóa deing chung chung cs230
chung chung
Đây khóa đình chung chung
cái khóa này thì đây cũng là thru thấy
dạy được chưa? CS230
cái bản à đây bản mới ấ mới năm ngoái
năm ngoái được chưa các bạn xem ở đây
nếu các bạn học theo cái khóa này thì
gần như các bạn cũng chả cần học cái
khóa của mình nữa. À th không phải không
phải cái khóa này là khóa dim link chung
chung các bạn sẽ có một cái khóa là dim
link dành cho computer vision CSR
stand for keep learning for computer
vision đây khóa C21N
khóa này cũng có trên YouTube đây trên
YouTube thì là đây
cô này cấy cũng là một cô rất là nổi nổi
tiếng của giáo sư gốc Trung rất là nổi
tiếng C231 chuyên về C vision
Thế còn không ấy các bạn mà đi show vào
cái khóa về NLP đây. NP là cái gì nhỉ?
CS234 cái gì nhở? CS234
không phải vẫn là C231
đây. C31 N à không phải đâu ấy nhỉ?
NP
nhở đây rồi.
C24N
này rất là ok, rất là tốt. Nó cũng có đủ
material cho các bạn. Các bạn có thể xem
ở đây material trong cái phần nhở
lecture video đây.
Lure video đây. Cái này thì bản mới nhất
là cái bản của khóa bao nhiêu ấy nhỉ? À
CS224N xem nào. CS
4N
đây. Mới nhất là khóa năm 2024 rất là
ok. Nhưng cái khóa nền tảng này các bạn
không không cần phải quá mới. Không cần
phải quá mới. Được chưa? Nó cũng đầy đủ
kiến thức. Thật ra ấy thì ba cái khóa là
deep learning, deep learning for
capation với cả Nature Language Pressing
với deep learning này nó khá là bổ trợ
nhau. Nó sẽ có nhiều kiến thức nó trùng
lặp nhau. Tại vì về cái bản chúng nó đều
về deep learning mà. Thế thì nếu các bạn
muốn tìm cái khoa học mà chất lượng
online free thì đây là ba nguồn
recomment cho các bạn. Được chưa? Thế
ngoài ra thì gần đây chúng ta sẽ có
những cái khóa về LM của Đ SF là bao
nhiêu? CS bao nhiêu nhỉ?
Đây khóa này là do hai anh em vừa làm
cái chi tiết họ đứng lớp đấy. Đây này.
Lastic model con này rất là hay rất là
ok. Đây hai anh này chính là hai cái anh
mà
hai anh em sinh đôi mà làm ra cái bản
chit đấy. Được chưa?
Kh này rất là ok. Rất là ok.
Rồi thì ngoài ra là còn có một vài những
cái nguồn khác ví dụ các bạn trên những
cái trang
bài chu trên cosera thầy Anru thì có một
vài cos thầ đẩy lên cosera nên nội dung
nó cũng khá là tương đồng thôi các bạn
học trên nguồn này là ok rồi trên Ca thì
lại tốn tiền cũng không cần thiết
không phải đâu các bạn ạ giáo sư thậm
chí cả PhD người ta cũng dạy nữa.
Ừ cả PhD người ta cũng dạy mà PhD hoặc
là professor professor họ bận lắm. PhD
thì họ sẽ có nhiều thế ăn hơn. Vậy theo
kinh nghiệm của mình ấ mình thấy là PhD
họ dạy họ dạy còn hay hơn. Ví dụ là
professor thì họ thiên mình nghiên cứu
nhiều. PhD thì họ kiểu cũng vừa
tức là họ thường họ sẽ trẻ hơn và họ
cũng vừa thường là họ cũng cái việc họ
học master cũng mới xong cái đấy cũng
không lâu nên là họ sẽ cách giảng họ sẽ
gần gũi nó sẽ dễ hiểu hơn còn các giáo
sư thì họ giảng hàn lắm.
[hắng giọng]
Ngày xưa mình học toàn học về PhD
professor ít lắm mà thường các ông
Professor dạy chán lắm các bạn.
Đấy.
Thế hồi ngày xưa hồi mình học ở Tim ấy
thì ngay kỳ đầu mình học luôn là
machining luôn. Mô đấy thì mình trượt.
Mình cho các bạn xem cái mình cho các
bạn xem cái đề thi đề này mà bây giờ
mình thi lại khả năng cao điểm cũng sẽ
không cao đâu ấ nhỉ
bạn. Chờ tí mình cho các bạn xem cái đề
thi của mình ngày xưa
đâu ấ nhỉ? À đây rồi đây
cái đề thi của mình à
đây là cái đây là đây mình mình bắt đầu
học cái cái kỳ mùa đông năm 2015 này
mấy Đức thành phố nào thế nó ná ná nhau
chạy chả khác gì mấy nhưng mà chắc là sẽ
có thành phố đẹp hơn à đây là mình học
kỳ mùa đông 2015
thi trong 120 phút
à bài thi tổng cộng là có
24 điểm
trên 16 điểm là đỗ dưới 16 là trượt.
Điểm của Đức thì nó khác với thế giới là
điểm của Đức nó đánh ngược. Điểm của Đức
là đánh từ 6 về 1. 6 với 5 là trượt. Bốn
là cái điểm đỗ thấp nhất càng gần 1 thì
càng tốt càng gần 5 càng 6 thì càng tồi.
Điểm nó chia đẻ đ, tức là gì? 1.0 này là
tốt nhất. Sau đó 1.3 1.7 2.0 lại 2.3 2.7
3.0 3.3 3.7 4.0 là điểm đỗ bét nhất rồi.
Trên 4.0 thì là trượt. Thế là điểm Đức
ấy các bạn thi điểm càng thấp thì càng
tốt.
Đây câu hỏi như này các bạn nhìn này.
Đây
môn này ngày xưa ngay kỳ đầu mình đăng
ký môn này môn tan tiến chỉ. Mô này mình
nhớ là thi đúng vào Valentine 2016.
Đúng van trai đúng 14 tháng 2 thi. Con
này mình trượt.
Môn này 16 điểm đỗ hình như mình được
mình được 12 điểm thì phải nửa.
Ừ 8 chỉ học lại chết luôn. Mà m này nó
chỉ họ m này nó chỉ cho học kỳ mùa đông
thôi.
Nó chỉ cho học kỳ mùa đông thôi. Nên là
mình phải chờ 1 năm sau mình học thi
lại. Thi lại mình cũng chỉ được khoảng
3.0. 3.0 điểm khá là thấp.
Mỗi này mình còn nhớ là cái hỗn lần mình
mình thi lại ấ giáo sư chấm chấm chấm
sai điểm cho mình. Thế là mình mình xin
phúc khảo và đúng là mình được lên điểm
thật. Giáo dư chấm sai mình một câu
nhưng mà anyway điểm cũng không cao lắm
đâ các bạn nhìn đề thi này bây giờ bây
giờ mấy câu này bây giờ có nhiều câu b
cho mình làm lại mình cũng chịu đây nhìn
như thế này
đây
toàn số với số
đấy
nàyy là môn machin so với môn này mình
không đánh giá cao. Đây cái slide mình
học thì như này mình không đánh giá cao
cách slide mình các bạn nhìn thấy không
trông
về gọi là gì về giao diện cũng không có
gì đặc biệt cả toàn số cũng không có gì
đặc biệt cũng không có gì giúp cho sinh
viên nó dễ nhớ hơn ngày xưa hồi mình học
đây mình cứ toàn đi mở mình cứ toàn tàn
tìm khóa của của Stanford học Stanford
họ họ họ họ họ dạy rất là dễ hiểu, rất
là dễ cái slide họ dạy trình bày dễ
hiểu, nó vẫn hàn lâm nhưng nó vẫn dễ
hiểu, vẫn dễu dễ hiểu hơn so với cái
slide của trường mình.
Đấy.
Đó thì mình có những kỳ sau mình học có
những môn là môn deep learning này. Rồi
deing for computeration rất là hay. Mình
vì deing thì lại thấy ok hơn. Deing thì
ví dụ ừ cái này thì nó cái chương trình
đào tạo nó có nó có những cái khóa thực
tập người ta bên đây người ta gọi là
người ta gọi là practicum. Practicum
tiếng Việt mình tiếng Anh người ta gọi
là practical cost. Đấy, cost tức là các
bạn sẽ
một là các bạn đi làm ở ngoài, hai là
các bạn làm ngoài trong trường. Trong
trường ta trong một cái project xong các
bạn chia nhó các bạn làm cuối kỳ làm
xong thì chấm điểm 10 tín chỉ.
Rồi ký cuối làm khóa luận à tức là gọi
là đồ án tốt nghiệp hết là masteris
cả chương trình đào tạo là 120 tín chỉ
chia làm 4 kỳ. Mỗi kỳ trung bình các bạn
phải hoàn thành 30 tín chỉ. Tức là trung
bình cứ mỗi kỳ các bạn hoàn thành 30 tín
chỉ là các bạn hết bốn kỳ. Nhưng mà
thường thường theo kinh nghiệm của mình
ở Đức ấy ít người hoàn thành đúng thời
hạn lắm. Thường sẽ phải kéo dài v trên
Đức nó khá là nặng.
Đức nó không siết đầu vào nhưng mà nó
siết đầu ra. Không siết đầu vào nghĩa là
gì? Tại vì là Đức nó miễn phí mà không
phải tốn tiền đâu. Mới Đức thì người ta
người ta quan niệm là cái việc học là
cái là cái quyền cơ bản của con người
nên là họ không thu học phí.
Tại vì nếu thu học phí ví dụ như ở Anh ở
Mỹ chẳng hạn thì phải ai cũng học được
đâu đúng không? Cứ sang Đức các bạn cứ
học trường công thì miễn là các bạn từ
mẫu giáo lên đến học lên thạc sĩ các bạn
sẽ không phải đóng tiền. Thật ra thì đầu
mỗi kỳ các bạn sẽ phải đóng khoảng ngày
xưa của mình là đầu mỗi kỳ là các bạn sẽ
phải đóng khoảng à
hơn 100 hơn 100 euro để làm thẻ tàu này
rồi à rồi rồi phí thư viện này rồi mấy
cái phí con con con. Nhưng mà chă moi
ngày xưa nó chỉ có khoảng gần 3 triệu
thôi. Tức là một một kỳ các bạn chỉ phải
đóng khoảng 3 triệu cái phí đấy thôi. Mà
nó cũng đều theo nó đều ấm vào các bạn
mà thư viện các bạn cũng dùng đúng
không? Rồi các bạn đi cũng phải đi xe
buýt các thứ đúng không? Mỗi kỳ các bạn
làm một cái thẻ như vậy. Nên ngày xưa
mình học hết năm kỳ.
D hết 5 kỳ thì mình có đúng năm cái thẻ
như vậy. Đây mình đây các bạn nhìn này
thẻ sinh viên mình đây.
Đấy 5 kỳ mỗi kỳ thì phải đóng một cái
một cái phí như này loanh quanh là cứ
khoảng là 1 đến 200. 200 ngày xưa thì
đấy nó chỉ khoảng 5 triệu thôi. Đấy mỗi
một kỳ một cái thẻ nhưế này học bình
thường học 4 kỳ là xong. Nhưng mà mình
phải hết 5 kỳ thì mình mới học xong.
Mỗi kỳ nếu mà các bạn hoàn thành được 30
tín chỉ thì coi như là các bạn ở hoàn
thành chỉ tiêu. Nhưng mà ngày xưa mình
học hai kỳ đầu thì mình vướng yêu đương
rồi cũng không để ý học hành nên là hai
kỳ đầu cộng lại mình học hết có đánh nhẽ
hai kỳ là phải hoàn thành 60 tín chỉ thì
hai kỳ đầu mình hoàn thành được có
19. Hai kỳ hoàn thành có 19 thôi. Thế
phải kéo dài 5 kỳ mới học xong.
bên này thì à cái phổ điểm cái phổ điểm
của cái bằng tốt nghiệp ấy à tức là sẽ
phổ điểm mà phân chia kiểu giỏi khá với
cả
giỏi khá với cả xuất sắc các thứ ấy thì
nó như thế này nó
không phải cái này rồi
nhá nhá.
NH thử giới thiệu các bạn một tí nhá.
Sau này bạn nào mà trong trong lớp mà có
bạn nào các bạn định đi du học mà các
bạn à ờ kiểu không có không có quá nhiều
điều kiện mà các bạn à không có quá
nhiều điều kiện để các bạn đi những cái
nước nói tiếng Anh và tiếng mẹ đẻ như
kiểu anh Úc Mỹ Ca New Zealand thì tốt
thì quá là tốt rồi. Mình nghĩ là tốt
nhất rồi nhưng mà những nước đấy thì học
phí nó đắt. Nế bạn nào các bạn muốn đi
du học theo kiểu là con nhà nghèo giống
như mình tức là mà các bạn không muốn đi
học ở Nhật Hàn Trung với nước xung quanh
các bạn phải cân nhắc đi các châu Âu mà
có thể giống như kiểu Đức.
Các bạn nhìn cái ben điểm của nó nhá.
Ben điểm đây.
Lớp mình chỉ có một bạn học ở Đức thôi
đúng không nhá. Cái ben điểm nó như mình
nói rồi. Điểm nó cứ càng gần 1 thì càng
tốt.
Trên 4 là hoảng. 4.0 thì là 4.0 thì là
cái điểm thấp nhất để các bạn đỗ. Thế
sau này khi mà điểm trung bình ấy, điểm
phẩy các bạn cứ từ 1 đến 1,5 thì nó là
zeg good. Z good. Tức là rất là tốt đấy.
Được chưa? 1.6 đến 2.5 thì là good
là cái bằng giỏi đấy đúng không? Đây là
bằng xuất sắc. V good là bằng xuất sắc
đấy. Good là bằng giỏi đấy. Thật ra phổ
điểm bằng giỏi của Đức nó rất là rộng.
Nó rộng hơn ở trên thế giới rất là nhiều
nên là hầu hết mọi người học là sẽ rơi
vào cái bảng vào cái phổ điểm này bằng
giỏi. Xong thì các bạn có bằng à bằng
khá bằng trung bình hoặc là trượt. Đấy
nhớ chưa? Ừ. Hầu hết hầu hết mọi người
Hầu hết mọi người học ở Đức ấy sẽ rơi
vào cái phổ điểm của bằng giỏi. Bằng phổ
điểm bằng giỏi nó rất là rộng. Nó rất
rộng.
Ờ
mình ngày xưa thì cái a
riêng cái đồ án của mình thì được 1.0
đây này
các bạn. Các bạn bỏ qua cái bế bên phải
bên phải tiếng Đức thôi. Khỏi phải nhìn
nhìn bên trái thôi. Cái cái đô của mình
thì mình 1.0 còn tổng điểm mình là 1.7.
1.7 cũng là gú thôi. Bên kia hầu hết mọi
người bạn bè mình đ quen thì đều là gú.
Có vài người lên được de good tức là rất
là xuất sắc ấy. Còn hầu hết mọi người
rơi về cái phổ điểm gú thì nó rất là
rộng. [khịt mũi]
Đây mình à cầm cái bằng này vào tháng 3
2018.
Cái bảng điểm của mình đây cho các bạn
xem. Bảng điểm của mình đây. Bảng điểm
này nó chỉ ghi những cái môn đỗ thôi.
Môn trượt nó không ghi.
Tổng 120 tín chỉ. Được chưa?
Điểm trung bình toàn chương trình là
1,7. Được chưa? À các bạn cứ nhìn cái
chỗ màu xanh nhá. Nó nó nó tiếng Anh chỗ
tiếng Đức các bạn bỏ qua. Đấy đồ án đây.
Đồ án tốt tốt tốt nghiệp mình đây. Đán
tốt nghiệp tí nữa mình tĩ có thời gian
mình show một tí. Còn những cái môn ở
dưới ví dụ như là đây đây một cái
practical cost này là cái practical cost
đầu tiên của mình này. Bên này gọi là
practicum thì đầu tiên được 2.0
Cái thứ hai thì một cái nữa được à cái
nữa thì được à
đây ví dụ cái môn machining này lần đầu
mình trượt đã lần hai được 2,7 à mình cứ
nhớ là được 3 2,7
đây cái practical code thứ hai thì đây
như này bên này nó cũng có một cái nữa
gọi là
gọi là interdisciplinary project tức là
gì học ở cái khoa này nhưng mà phải đến
cái khoa khác để làm cái practical này
và cái môn này sẽ có 16 tín chỉ. Môn này
mình cũng làm không tốt lắm. Được 2,5
mình sang cái khoa điện mình làm cũng
không tốt lắm.
Có mấy cái môn phụ ví dụ là mình lấy a
để à ăn điểm cho dễ thì mình đăng ký cái
môn học tiếng Đức. Tại vì tiếng Đức
trước khi sao mình cũng học rồi. Mình
tiếng Đức mình cũng mình cũng không nói
được nhưng mà tiếng Đức này bằng chứng
cái đây cái level thấp nhất thì nó rất
là dễ thôi. Học toàn a bấy mà. Học môn
này điểm cho nó dễ. kiếm điểm cho nó dễ
thế thôi. Đấy nên bạn nào sao các bạn
cân nhắc các bạn muốn đi du học mà các
bạn à tính phí nó không có nhiều giống
như nhà mình ngày xưa thì các bạn cứ đi
sang mấy cái nước này nhiều nước lắm Đức
này mấy nước khác châu Âu cũng thế cơ
chứ không phải có mỗi Đức đâu thế
nhưng mà một trong số những cái lý do mà
mình riêng Đức tại vì là Đức nó có nhiều
trường rank nó rất là cao. Các bạn tĩ
xong giờ nghỉ ra mình chỉ các bạn một
vài cái trang để các bạn tìm rank của
cái trường sau này các bạn mà bn ghi cân
nhắc các bạn đi du học các bạn có thể
ngoài cái việc miễn phí thì các bạn xem
trường ranh rủng như thế nào đúng không
thì mình sẽ chỉ các bạn cách để các bạn
xem rankh của ngày trường nhá
ok thôi
ok
có câu hỏi gì không
lớp mình à trong số những bạn đang học
là à đang đang đang đang đang đang ở
trong a trong buổi hôm nay Có những bạn
nào các bạn định là sau này có mục tiêu
đi các bạn đi dòm nước ngoài không? Bạn
nào các bạn định đi ru nước ngoài các
bạn cho số 1 được không?
Monix nó mon nó nhiều công ty to lắm em
ạ. Mà công ty to đến sin nó khó lên bin
nó là cái half của half của startup nó
toàn startup thì việc nó dễ.
Với lại với lại nhá các bạn cứ tưởng
tượng là ở Mic ấy nó có hai trường lớn
đúng không là Tonic và cả trường LMU
đúng không? Cái trường LQ cái trường LQ
thì rank nó cao nó cũng ngang ngửa T Mix
tức là tất cả những ông nào mà ở mà ở
Monex ấy thì hầu hết là sẽ học từ hai
cái trường này đúng không? Và một vài
cái trường một vài cái trường Fuler nữa.
Một vài cái trường dưới. Nhưng mà nhìn
chung là ở cái thành phố Mic này sẽ rất
nhiều ông là từ trường mình và từ cái
trường kia.
Thì có nghĩa là bây giờ mình cầm cái
bằng của Ton X kể cả Tonic nó có rank 1
của Đức đi nữa nhưng mà bây giờ mình ở
mình ở một cái thành phố mà ông nào cũng
tốt nghiệp từ cái trường này thì mình
chả có chả có một cái lợi thế gì cả đúng
không? Từ Đức thì lại không biết đến từ
một cái đất nước mà cũng không phải
trong liên minh châu Âu đúng không? Thì
khi mình ở lại MX thì mình chả có một
cái l cạnh tranh gì cả b giạt biên ra
thành phố khác thì cầm cái bằng nó sẽ có
giá trị hơn đúng không? Các bạn cầm cầm
bằng của MIT xong các bạn ở trong một
cái thành phố mà toàn người tốt nghiệp
của MIT chẳng hạn thì các bạn chả có cái
lợi thế gì cả đúng không? Không chỗ nào
nhẹ chỗ nào dễ thì mình chui vào thôi.
Rồi
ok.
À cả lớp chỉ một một bạn thôi à. Ok. Rồi
có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Rồi thế chúng ta nghỉ giải lao 5 phút
rồi chúng ta nói tiếp các bạn nhá. 5
phút nhá.
Mà nào các bạn muốn hỏi gì các bạn cứ
hỏi nhá. Mình vẫn ngồi trước máy thôi
nhá.
Sắ mớ
chi vì sinh hoạt đấy. Ừ cũng cũng mình
nghĩ là mình nghĩ là sau cái đợt mà Nga
về Ukraina đánh nhau thì chi phí nó tăng
lên. Thế nhưng mà nếu mà các bạn à nếu
mà các bạn kiểu có kể cả các bạn đang
làm sinh viên các bạn đi làm kiểu
working student tức là mỗi một tuần các
bạn làm 10 đến 20 các bạn làm 20 tiếng
như mình ngày xưa chẳng hạn thôi mình ở
MIC ngày xưa mình từ học kỳ thứ ba đến
học kỳ năm trong 1 năm rưỡ mình đi làm
working student thì cái chi phí mà công
ty nó trả cho mình mình coi như là vừa
áp dụng cái gì học trên trường vào công
việc luôn và cái chi phí người ta trả đủ
để mình cover chị cover các thứ mà ừ mít
thì đắt nhưng mà lương nó cũng cao mà
m đắt thì đắt thật nhưng mà lương nó
cũng cao Mà đ lương nó chắc là top cao
nhất của đất đất nước rồi. Thành phố nào
mà chi phí đắt thì lương cao,
chi phí ít thì lương ít thôi. Ừ. Berlin
thì rẻ hơn.
Mình thấy tương quan giữa Berlin với cả
Munich nó cũng giống như kiểu Hà Nội với
Hồ Chí Minh ấy. Hà Nội thì là thủ đô về
thủ đô về hành chính đúng không? Thế
nhưng mà nói về gọi là nói về sự phát
triển, nói về mức độ ờ gọi là gì nhỉ?
nói về độ phát triển này, nói về cơ hội
việc làm, nói về mức sống các thứ thì
chắc chắn là chắc chắn là Hồ Chí Minh
hơn rồi đúng không? Thì Berlin về mic nó
cũng y chang như vậy. Berlin thì là thủ
đô. Thế nhưng mà nói về mặt bằng chung
các thứ ấ thì
thì
cái này hay nhỉ? Xếp lại thì xem làm nào
thì Monic nó hơn nhiều. Về Việt Nam mình
toàn thấy mọi người Nam Tiến. Tức là
bạn bè mình anh chị em họ mình đi du học
toàn đổ từ Hà Nội và Hồ Chí Minh chứ
mình cũng chưa quen ông nào lại đi từ Hồ
Chí Minh ra Hà Nội bao giờ.
Các bạn các bạn cứ các bạn cứ vào các
bạn cứ vào học cái trường công là các
bạn được auto miễn phí rồi. Thế nhưng mà
một vài năm trở ở đây thì có một vài
bang ở Đức ờ một vài cá cái trường ở một
vài cái bang ở Đức họ xin họ yêu cầu tự
chủ. Bây giờ có một vài trường họ đã thu
học phí rồi
bao gồm cả bao gồm cả trường mình. Vì ti
mic nó cũng thu học phí rồi. Mỗi kỳ như
là mỗi một kỳ như là tùy tùy chương
trình học các bạn sẽ đóng từ khoảng 4000
đến 6000 chứ không không có được free
như ngày xưa nữa. Bây gi nhiều trường
rất là những cái trường top họ yêu cầu
là họ tự chủ học phí để tức là tự chủ
cái thu nhập để họ có thể chủ động hơn
trong việc là đầu tư các thứ.
Đức thì nó sẽ có hai cái kiểu đại học nó
sẽ có hai kiểu. Mọi là Universitet, tức
là University đấy là trường đại học kiểu
là học
ừ gọi là đại học theo hướng theo hướng
là nghiên nghiên cứu. Đây chưa? Mình học
có một cái dạng nữa là pack of Schulher.
Fake of Schulher là cái trường kiểu đại
học ứng dụng.
Đại học ứng dụng, đại học dứng hợp dụng
thường nó học nó sẽ có thể nó sẽ nhẹ hơn
một chút th học nó sẽ ngắn hơn. Ví dụ
học master của Đại học ứng dụng thì nó
chỉ có 3 kỳ thôi, 1 năm rưỡi. Thế còn
master của Universitet thì nó sẽ có 4 kỳ
là 2 năm. Nhưng mà cái nào thì cũng thì
th thì cũng tốt cả.
Ok.
Đúng rồi. Ở Đức nó có một cái ru tức là
gì? Đã được miễn học phí rồi thì phải
học tử tế. Nếu cùng một môn mà thi trượt
đến lần thứ ba ấy sẽ không được học cái
chương trình đấy. Ví dụ mình học công
nghệ tim mình học informatic đi đúng
không? Nếu mình trượt một cái môn nào đó
ở trong chương trình học của mình, mình
sẽ không được học mình sẽ không được học
cái informatic ở bất kỳ một cái trường
nào ở nước Đức nữa. Nếu muốn học mình
phải sang học khác học về kinh tế chẳng
hạn. Kiểu như vậy. Không được thi trưởng
môn ba lần.
Ngày xưa hồi mình mới biết cái trò này
mình sợ lắm tại vì mình sợ là mình đã
từng mình biết có những người học đến kỳ
cuối rồi
mà có một môn mà không thể đỗ được thi
trượt đúng ba lần. Thế là học đến kỳ 7ả
rồi, tức là học ba ch học bảy kỳ, học
đến kỳ 7ả rồi cũng không lấy được vào.
Tại vì trượt trượt là trượt thôi, trượt
ba lần là thôi.
Không, nếu đấy là môn tự chọn thì còn
lấy được nhưng mà khốn lỗi là cái môn
chế đấy là môn bắt buộc. Muôn bắt buộc
thì chịu rồi.
Đấy nó không siết đầu vào nhưng mà nó
cũng sẽ có những cái yêu cầu. Thế còn
các bạn học ở Anh Mỹ thì các bạn như
trệt các bạn các bạn cứ cứ đ cứ đóng
tiền mà các bạn thi cho mấy bao giờ đỗ
thì thôi đúng không? Nhưng mà ở Đức thì
còn lâu. Đức thì trượt một ba lần là
nghỉ về nhà.
Rồi
rồi. Thế bây giờ thì mình muốn a
à cho mình hỏi một tí. Trong những bạn
đang đang ngồi trong cái buổi học hôm
nay có bạn nào mà các bạn trong tương
lai các bạn sẽ đi xin việc? Các bạn cho
mình số một. Còn bạn nào mà các bạn đang
có job rồi các bạn cho mình số hai được
không?
À có nhiều bạn có chóp đâ đ này.
Thì bây giờ ấy mình muốn là
trời các bạn mới vừa nằm điều hòa ra cổ
hỏng quá. Bây giờ mình muốn dành nốt cái
thời lượng còn lại của buổi hôm nay để
mình à
học thì chúng ta khoay chúng ta nói về
kiến thức kiến thức rồi đúng không? thực
hành rồi mọi thứ rất là nhiều rồi thì
bây gi mình muốn dành cái này để mình
muốn gọi là gì nhỉ? Gọi là có lẽ gọi là
chia sẻ đi. Mình muốn chia sẻ với các
bạn cái cái cái kinh nghiệm của bản thân
mình trong cái quá trình tức là chia sẻ
kinh nghiệm khi làm sao để xây dựng
profile này xin việc xin việc như thế
nào đúng không? Làm sao để làm đẹp cái
profile của mình, làm sao cho cái
profile mình nó nổi bật so với những
người khác làm sao để tăng cơ hội các
bạn đi xin việc. Tại vì suy cho cùng thì
học gì thì học nhưng mà cái mục tiêu
cuối cùng chúng ta nó vẫn là vẫn là đi
xin việc đúng không? Đi xin việc đúng
không? Học các bạn học mốn học whatever
nhưng mà đến cuối cũng phải đi xin việc
mà. Được chưa? Thì mình sẽ chia sẻ các
bạn về cái về cái lộ trình của mình. Có
thể sẽ có những cái thứ mà nó sẽ áp dụng
được vào cho các bạn và có thể có những
thứ các bạn nó sẽ không áp dụng được cho
các bạn. Đấ đầu tiên mình muốn nói qua
một chút về mình. Thì cái hồi ngày xưa
ấy mình học đại học ở Bách Khoa ấy thì
mình tốt nghiệp năm 2014.
Nhưng mà cái lúc mà mình mới tốt nghiệp
ấy thì profile của mình nó trắng trơn,
nó chả có cái gì cả ngoài cái bằng đại
học. Đấy mình chưa từng đi làm bao giờ.
Kinh nghiệm của mình, kinh nghiệm làm
việc mình hoàn toàn là con số.
Ngày xưa hồi một trong số những cái lý
do mà mình đi du học ấy tại vì là mình
sợ đi xin việc. Tại vì các bạn bảo là
bây giờ các bạn hãy thử nghĩ mà xem bây
giờ nhá. Tốt người Bách Khoa bằng giỏi.
Thế nhưng mà nhưng mà ngay trong trường
mình Bách Khoa bằng giỏi thì nó cũng có
thiếu gì đâu. Thiếu nhiều lắm. Chưa kể
có những cái trường khác nhá. Chưa nói
đến trong miền Nam chỉ nói trên miền Bắc
thôi nhá. Bây giờ còn bưu trình biễn
thông đại học quốc gia đủ các thể loại
nữa đúng không? Rồi còn có cả FPT. Rồi
ngày xưa còn có cả ngày xưa cái thời của
mình ấy có hai cái trường mà họ đào tạo
theo cái hướng ứng dụng rất là hay đó là
FPT với cảch.
Mình cũng chả biết vì sao mà cái cái
thường ngày xưa mình nó rất là hot.
Uptech app rất là hot nhưng mà lúc bây
giờ mình mình về từ mình về nước đến giờ
bây giờ mình không nghe nhiều người ta
nói đến uptech nữa mình không biết là
bây giờ cái cái trường đấy nó như thế
nào rồi nhưng mà ngày xưa có rất nhiều
bạn học của mình thậm chí nhá có những
bài học của mình tức là họ vừa học Bách
Khoa vừa học FPT hoặc là vừa học gì đấy
tại vì cái chương trình của mấy thằng
kia nó chỉ có 2 năm rưỡ thôi mà nó thiên
về ứng dụng nó thiên về thực hành Bách
Khoa này nhiều lý thuyết quá
nhiều bạn học của mình thì năm 2 năm ba
họ bắt đầu họ đi thực tập họ đi làm ở
công ty tích kinh nghiệm rồi còn mình
mình chả biết cái gì mình chỉ tập trung
mình học thôi. Thế là lúc mình ra trường
mình kinh nghiệm làm việc bằng 0 nên
mình rất là sợ đi xin việc. Chả biết là
lấy mình ngoài cái việc là mình có sổ đỏ
ở nhà ở Hà Nội thì mình mình cũng không
không thấy mình có một cái lợi thế gì so
với những người khác cả. Mà cái sổ đỏ ấy
cũng không thể dùng để đi apply xin việc
được. Thế là mình xin đi du học coi như
là delay cái thời gian đi xin việc.
Thế thì ngày xưa cái lúc mà lúc mình đi
học du học ấ lúc mà mình đến khoảng kỳ 4
kỳ năm học trình học thạc sĩ sắp tốt
nghiệp rồi mình rất là lo cái đi xin
việc. Tại vì là ngày xưa ở Việt Nam
còn chưa ni bây giờ ra bây giờ bây giờ
bây giờ bây giờ ra nước ngoài tiếng Đức
thì không biết chả biết cái gì cả thì
bây giờ làm sao để làm sao để xin biểu
bây giờ lấy cái gì trong CV tại vì như
mình nói đúng không
Ở Đức ấy nó có rất nhiều trường top rank
rất là cao.
Nói đến nói đến rank à nói đến tìm rank
của trường nhá. Mình mình mình nói nhanh
các bạn nhá. Vừa nói vừa flex một thể
luôn. Nó có ba cái trang. Bạn nào các
bạn quan tâm đến tìm rankh của trường
ấy, trường quốc tế đúng không? Trường
International Worldwide ấ thì các bạn sẽ
có ba cái nền tảng chính. Một là các bạn
vào cái trang của
igener Education. Times
Higer Education Ranking như này nhá. Một
là đây mình chỉ ba cái trang uy tín nhất
thế giới. Ranking đây được chưa? World
of ranking 2026 này. Được chưa? Đây rank
có cái trường trên toàn thế giới đây. Ờ
top đầu thì toàn Anh với cả Mỹ thôi.
Khỏi phải nghĩ t anh Mỹ thôi. Các bạn
cũng thể các bạn sẽ rank theo theo
subject cũng được. Ví dụ các bạn theo s
nhá. Ví dụ mình quan tâm đến camera s
đây đúng không? Đây cam s này. Đấy được
chưa? Cam s này. Đấy các bạn sẽ nhìn cái
rank như này. Đấy các bạn có nhiều cái
thêm nhiều khác nữa. Đây mình theo
camera s nhá.
Đâu rồi? Đây cam s nhá.
Đây cam như này đúng không? Hầu hết cái
top đầu toàn là của
sao lạ nhỉ? Sao nó sẽ may mấy cái trường
của anh lên cao nhỉ? Đây đúng không? Có
vậy toàn anh với Mỹ là nhiều đúng không?
Anh với Mỹ nhiều này.
Đẹp Bắc Kinh này. Đẹp Bắc Kinh này. Được
chưa? Đẹp gì đây các bạn? Trường còn lại
của Bắc Kinh này. Trường này là trường
gì đây các bạn?
Trường gì đây?
Bạn biết trường này trường Thanh Hoa
đúng không? Đng đánh rất là cao.
quốc gia Singapore này.
[hắng giọng]
Này chườ mình này
[ho]
chường mình này được chưa? Nanang của
Singapore này. Được chưa?
Đây là cái xếp hạng các bạn theo phân
chia theo theo ngành ví dụ theo
camersion. Còn không thì các bạn theo
chung chung thôi. Tôi không phân tôi
không phân chia cụ thể thôi. Chung chung
thôi. Rank tổng rank tổng được chưa?
Rank tổng thì nó cũng ranh tổng tất
nhiên là đây xuống dướ đâ nóng xo này
đúng không? Ranh tổng như này đây chư
mình nó nằm dưới này không chữa Việt Nam
thì không tìm trong tốt này đâu các bạn
ạ. Việt Nam giờ ông vào đây đâu nhá.
Được không?
Ví dụ bây giờ mình muốn tìm riêng ở của
một quốc gia đi. Tìm riêng của một quốc
gia nhá.
Rank đây trường ranking của Châu Á này.
Châu Á nhá. Châu Á này. Ranking này
thanh này. Việt Nam mình nhét vào đâu
nhỉ? À đây này. Mình sẽ xem theo theo
theo theo theo quốc gia ở đâu ấy nhỉ?
Bộ lọc đây đây location đây nhá. Việt
Nam nhá. Đây này. Việt Nam này.
Này trường rank cao này. Trên này trường
gì ấ nhở?
Chương gì các bạn nhỉ?
À đọc kinh tế à ừ đèo kinh tế Hồ Chí
Minh ranh cao này các bạn ranh cao vút
này.
[hắng giọng]
Duy Tân Tôn nữ Thắng hai chên này bao
giờ rank cũng cao tân thô nữ Thắng thì
rank auto cao.
Rank này là rank a
à ừ ừ ừ rankh Châu Á thôi. Rank ừ ranh
châu Á. Ừ
có đúng không nhỉ? Đ ranh chêu bá hay là
ranh
từ từ thử đây nhá. Thử đây nhá.
À ừ ừ ừ. Đây đây mà ranh quốc tế này. Ừ
đang bảo la sao tiện rank cao thế? Ừ mà
cũng là cao đúng không các bạn? 5 th
cũng là cao mà đúng không? Đây đ trường
Việt Nam đây. Bách khóa tít dưới này
đây. Hà tít dướ này được chưa?
tìm quốc gia nhá. Ví dụ mình tìm
ví dụ mình tìm c ở Đức nhá.
Miễn phí mà chiều nhiều trường danh cao
lắm các bạn. Đây này các bạn nhìn này.
Đây này. Ở mô nó có hai thành vố ngay
gần nhau
nhá. Các bạn biết là ở Munic có cái sân
v Alian Arena ấy thì cái trường LMU này
là tầm khoảng hai ba bến trước cái sân
đấy. Còn trường mình là sau cái sân đấy
hai ba bến. Trường mình là ở bến cuối
luôn. Chư mình làở bên cuối luôn đấy.
Hai ch này đều ở mic rank rất là cao mà
đều miễn phí cả. Đều miễn phí cả. Mấy
trường dưới cũng thế này các bạn không
các bạn thấy không? Bây giờ bây giờ bây
giờ các bạn không phải tốn tiền học mà
các bạn được vào những cái trường ví dụ
là top 100 thế giới chẳng hạn thì cũng
khá là ok đúng không? Mà mà chương trình
học đâ chương trình học thạc sĩ nó có
nhiều chương bn tiếng Anh lắm. Mình học
tiếng Anh mà mình tiếng Đức mình có biết
chữ nào đâu đúng không?
Đấy
nếu mà top 10 các bạn thấy là các bạn đã
có tám trường rồi.
Nếu các bạn học bao thì gần như các bạn
sẽ phải học bằng tiếng Đức nhưng mà các
bạn học bằng học master thì các bạn học
tiếng Anh thôi. Nhưng mình thì học mình
ở đến 10 năm rồi mình có biết biết chữ
tiếng Đức nào đâu. Người Đức người ta
nói tiếng ức người ta người Châu Âu
người ta nói tiếng Anh giỏi lắm.
Đây này ở ví dụ ở Berlin có trường TU
Berlin này cũng rất là mạnh này. Rất là
mạnh nhanh rất là cao này các bạn nhìn
đây nếu mà mình đếm qua nhá đúng không?
Top top top top top top top top top 10
thì có tám trường rồi. Top 200 thì cũng
phải đến top 200 thì cũng phải đến hơn
chục trường đúng không? Ranh thế giới
đấy. Hơn chục trường mà lại không phải
tốn học phí. University of B. B là bon
là cái gì nhở? Cô của của
không phải cố đô không? Cái cái trường
này rất đặc biệt. Trường này nó còn đến
hơn 205 tuổi rồi.
Đức nó có một cái lên minh là Tu9. Tu9 ở
Đức này. Liên minh chín trường đại học
kỹ thuật mạnh nhất của Đức.
này các bạn vào chỗ nào cũng tốt
đây chín ông đâu ấy nhỉ?
Chín trường là
đâu ấy nhỉ?
Đây chín cái trường này liên minh chín
trường đây tu monic này tuin này. Đ ờ
trường đại học sugard này đại học ở
LPSIC này thấy tất trường này rank rất
là cao nó rank rất cao bạn vào trường
nào cũng ok đúng không đây là một bảng
xếp hạng được chưa bảng xếp hạn thứ hai
là kiểu QS QS ranking đây cái bản này
cũng rất là uy uy uy tín cách tìm cũng
tương tự như vậy ranking nhá
world ranking nhá được chưa đây MIT số 1
này đúng không mình mà rank theo mình mà
rank theo theo theo theo
đây. Đây tranh theo a
để đến 2027 gì mà sớm ấy nhỉ.
Đấy rất nhiều này đúng không? Rất nhiều
này các bạn xem nà. Nó sẽ không giống
nhau hoàn toàn đâu. Nó sẽ lệch nhau một
tí. Đấy rất nhiều trường này chỉ hầu hết
top 10 với top 20 hầu hết là hầu hết là
Mỹ về Anh là phần lớn thêm cả mấy hai
cái trường của của của Trung Quốc nữa.
Gì thế này?
Đây theo theo theo subject nhá. Ví dụ
theo subject nhá. Ví dụ theo
theo theo theo đâu rồi?
Ở đâu ấy nhỉ?
À đây engine technology đây nhá. Được
chưa? Về kỹ thuật nhá. Được chưa? Em đi
thứ này chưa?
Đây chuyền mình như này đây đây năm nay
lên ranh ranh cao nhở mọi năm rank không
cao này đâu đấy như này thấy chưa cũng
có thể chúng ta lọc theo quốc gia lộc
quốc gia đây Việt Nam này
đây
giờ này được chưa đây Duy Tân này Tô Đức
Thắng đâu ấy nhỉ
đấy vâng và cái trang cuối là của Đại
học Tược Hải ấy Shang 2 University
Ranking Đây
cũng tương tự như vậy. Các bạn cứ search
theo ví dụ set reason ví dụ nhá. Mình sẽ
thử nhá. Ví dụ
tất nhiên là các bản xếp hạng thì thống
trị đều là của Anh với cả Mỹ rồi thì hai
nước đấy thì khỏi phải bàn đi nhưng mà
ngoài ra chúng ta xem những nước khác
như nào. Nãy mình Đức nhá. Đây rank quốc
gia thì là rank đây. Rank thế giới thì ở
đây được chưa? World rank đây. Rank quốc
gia đây. Được chưa?
Đây là cái trường còn lại trường mình
đây này. Mỗi bạn xem nó sẽ khác nhau một
tí. dụ xem của Việt Nam nhá. Việt Nam
nhá.
Việt Nam dưới cùng này. Rồi
đâu ấy nhỉ?
Đâu ấy nhỉ?
Mình có bỏ sót không nhỉ? Đâu ấy nhỉ?
Hình như là không có thì phải.
Đấy nhá. Thế thôi quay lại quay lại nói
về cái chủ đề là s profile nào thì
mình thấy là với những bạn học à học AI
học datent học machine nói chung à nói
riêng cũng như là những bạn học IT nó
nói chung ấy thì có một cái hướng mà các
bạn ấy rất hay làm đó là các bạn ấy sẽ
ờ sẽ ví dụ như có thể là các bạn ấy ờ
tham gia vào những cái cuộc thi trên các
hấy
những cái chứng chỉ ví dụ như những cái
chứng chỉ trên Cera hoặc là Udemi chẳng
hạn
Đấy có hai hướng một là thi trên các g
hướng này nhá
mình sẽ nói về cái hướng này trước
các bạn đế b đế biết cái trang này đúng
không các nó là một cái platform lớn
nhất thế giới về dat và machin nó bao
gồm cả những cái bộ dữ liệu rồi code rồi
đủ mọi thứ về machin
trên này nó có một cái phần rất là hay
đó những cái competition competition
những cái cuộc thi rất là hay có những
cuộc thi và có cả phần thưởng bằng tiền
ho nhá đúng Đúng không? Rất nhiều cuộc
thi này, rất nhiều cuộc thi thì rất là
có giá trị và được support bởi những ông
lớn ví dụ như là Google là Microsoft.
Thì nếu mà các bạn đạt được những cái
thứ hạng cao trên những cái cuộc thên
các này thì nó là một cái điều rất là
tốt thì nó có thể cho vào CV. Tuy nhiên
với mình thì mình không có khuyến khích
các bạn lắm. Các bạn tham gia những cuộc
thi này.
Mình không khuyến khích lắm. Tại vì sao?
Tại vì là nó có một vài lý do. Đồng ý là
nó có giải thưởng, giải thưởng lớn và
nếu mà các bạn có cái dải top thứ hạng
cao thì nó rất là tốt trong CV bạn. Thế
nhưng mà thứ nhất ấy là nếu mà những cái
cuộc thi mà uy tín, những cái cuộc thi
của những ông lớn ấy mà muốn đạt giải
cao thì cực kỳ khó. Tại vì các bạn nhìn
thấy các bạn nhìn số team này thấy chưa?
Các bạn nhìn thấy số team này đúng
không? Toàn là hàng nghìn team mà các
bạn biết là những cái team này có rất
nhiều team là họ gần như là họ rất là
nghiêm túc, rất là serious. Tức là họ có
cả team rồi họ có cả mentor họ gần như
là họ chỉ tập trung để là tâm ra cuộc
thi này thôi. Các bạn mà là cá nhân hoặc
kể cả các bạn có rủ được thêm một vài
người bạn nữa ấy thì khả năng mà các bạn
có thể dồn thời gian full time cho một
cái cuộc thi này rất là khó. Rất là khó.
Thế và trong những cái team kia có thể
mentor họ có kinh nghiệm rất là nhiều
thì rất là khó để các bạn có thể vượt
qua được họ. Cái cái thứ nhất. Cái thứ
hai nữa là tức là cái thứ các bạn bỏ ra
rất là nhiều. Tất nhiên các bạn cũng sẽ
học được một cái gì đấy nhưng mà để các
bạn được cái rank cao ở trong thế này
rất là khó. gần như rất là khó. Còn
những còn những cuộc cái cuộc thi bé bé
nhỏ nhỏ mà chả ai để ý thì các bạn được
rank cao người ta nó cũng không có giá
trị nhiều.
Đấy là cái thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai nữa là
bản thân những cái cuộc thi không phải
chính các mà những cuộc thi nói chung
chung ấy thì cái tính chất của nó sẽ
không phản ánh cái thứ mà doanh nghiệp
họ cần. Vì sao? Các tẩn tới thường những
cô thiế này ấy người ta thường người ta
sẽ đánh giá ví dụ mô hình của các cái
team chẳng hạn theo cái tiêu chí là gì
là ông nào có độ chính xác càng cao thì
càng tốt đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn tham
gia ra một cái bộ thi về bài toán phân
loại đi thì có phải là
bây giờ cái mô hình các bạn mà cái độ
chính xác cái a ví dụ cái điểm cái ví dụ
là F1 score cao nhất thì các bạn là top
1 cao nhì là top 2 đúng không? người ta
chỉ dựa vào cái performance với mô hình
của các bạn thôi. Và tuy nhiên sau này
các bạn đi làm nó sẽ có nhiều yếu tố
khác người ta sẽ cân nhắc người ta sẽ
quan trọng hơn cả cái việc đấy. Trong
buổi học lý thuyết chúng mình nói rồi
đúng không? Ví dụ là triển khai như thế
nào? Triển khai ví dụ các bạn mô hình
các bạn tốt nhưng mà nó chạy lâu chẳng
hạn thì sẽ không thể nào nó so bằng
những cái mô hình khác được. Được không?
Thế
các bạn chờ mình một tí nhá. Ch mình
mình xem một tí
chạy server một chút đã
cho mình xin phép 1 phút nhá. 1 phút,
1 phút, 1 phút.
Rồi ok tiếp các bạn nhá. Thế thế nên là
ờ mình không có recom mình không có
recom lắm tham những cái cuộc thi trên
các này. Bản thân mình bé giờ mình cũng
chưa từng bao giờ mình tham gia những
cuộc thi này. Mình thấy là đấy thứ nhất
là nó không phản ánh cái gì thực tế công
ty nó cần, doanh nghiệp họ cần. Thứ hai
là rất là khó để đặt rank cao bây giờ kể
cả các bạn bảo mình tham gia công ty này
mình rất là khó mình đạt rank cao tại vì
là khó lắm các bạn. Khó lắm. Đấy đây là
cái cái cách thứ nhất. Cách thứ hai là
có nhiều bạn mà các bạn đấy đây cái cách
thứ hai cách mà ngày xưa bản thân mình
cũng từng từng từng dùng trong cái đầu
của hồi ngày xưa mình là sinh viên đó là
các bạn lên cái nền tảo như là Cera hoặc
là Udem các bạn học các bạn thi cái
chứng chỉ
nhưng mà cách này thì mình cũng không
recommend các bạn cho lắm tại vì sao thứ
nhất là
những cái chứng chỉ mà các bạn thi ấy
thì à có thể có cái miễn phí có có thể
có cái thu phí à có thể cái miễn phí có
thể có cái thu phí nhưng mà cái vấn đề
là thật ra là để thi được cái chứng chỉ
này nó nó rất là dễ cái chứng chỉ như là
kiểu trên cos x ud hoặc là s ấy nó rất
là dễ gần như là ai cũng thể có được thế
nên là cái việc mà các bạn hoàn thành
các bạn có khoảng chục cái chứng chỉ như
vậy nó cũng chả thể hiện nhiều mấy vì
gần như ấy các bạn ạ gần như các bạn chỉ
cần các bạn các bạn chỉ có cái khả năng
tư duy IQ trung bình thôi các bạn học
các bạn
xem đủ các cái bài là các bạn sẽ làm t
vì là những cái bài người ta thiết kế
làm sao các bạn xem bài học và các bạn
sẽ làm được thôi, không phải nó không có
nó không có channel, nó không có thử
thách nhiều đâu. Thế nên là các bạn mà
có những cái chứng chỉ trên những cái
nền tảng online như vậy nó cũng không có
nhiều ý nghĩa.
Không nó không có nhiều ý nghĩa. Thế thì
đấy là hai cách mà người ta hay làm.
Cách thứ ba là cách của mình làm. Cách
mình làm là gì? Là mình xây dựng cái
profile trên kit thắp.
Tại vì sao? Tại vì là
sao? Tại vì là
ờ
các bạn không biết các bạn các bạn đều
biết GitHub đúng không? Các bạn đều biết
GitHub. Ờ GitHub nó là cái nền tảng nó
giống kiểu là cái mạng xã hội dành dành
cho lập trình viên á đúng không? Có các
bạn đã biết GHP đúng không?
Nó giống như cái nền tảng nó là cái mạng
mạng xã hội dành cho lập trình viên. Tức
là nơi mà các cái lập trình viên những
cá nhân cho chúng ta, chúng ta có thể
chia sẻ code của chúng ta những cái
project cá nhân cho lên đấy. Thế còn các
công ty họ có thể họ dùng git để họ có
thể lưu trữ những cái source code của họ
đúng không? Hầu hết các bạn đều đã từng
dùng gitub. Thế nhưng mà phần lớn chúng
ta phần lớn chúng ta chúng ta thường
chúng ta hay sử dụng git hub chứ chỉ là
cái nơi để các bạn lên đấy các bạn git
clone các bạn for những cái report về.
rất ít người chịu đầu tư trong cái thảnh
ghop này. Thế nhưng mà tuy nhiên thì
theo mình thì nếu mà các bạn dành thời
gian, các bạn chăm chút, các bạn xây
dựng cái tài khoản GUP nó đủ mạnh thì nó
sẽ rất là tốt cho các bạn trong quá
trình các bạn đi xin lượt sau này. Tại
vì sao? Tại vì trong một rừng những
người người ta không quan tâm đến xây
dựng GitHub và các bạn có một cái tài
khoản Ghub tốt thì đấy là một cái điểm
đặc biệt của các bạn.
Ví dụ như mình ngày xưa từ cái hồi trước
khi mình ra trường mình đã bắt đầu mình
à bắt đầu mình chăm chút và mình mong
mái cho thả ghép của mình. Đây là tài
khoản của mình các bạn. Các bạn cũng
không cần phải đế mức như này. Tại vì
thật ra cái với với cái thời buổi hiện
nay để có được những tản giub những cái
repit hub mà có nhiều nhiều star nó rất
là khó. Nó khó hơn thời ngày xưa của
mình. Th ngày xưa mình cái AI nó chưa
phát triển nên là nó dễ hơn. Còn bây giờ
thì rất là khó. Thế vì sao mình lại bảo
các bạn là các bạn nên xây dựng cho mình
một cái tài khoản G Hub tốt? Tại vì như
này lý nhất như mình vừa mới nói rồi,
người khác họ không gần như là rất ít
người họ họ thực sự họ đầu tư họ xây
dựng tài khoản GitHub. Thế nên là khi mà
các bạn có thì đấy là một cái sự khác
biệt. Thứ hai nữa ấy là GitHub là cái
nơi mà các bạn show diễn gần như là show
diễn hết tất cả những cái gọi là bộ kỹ
năng hay là những cái ờ gọi là những cái
project cá nhân của các bạn đúng không?
Ờ các bạn sẽ không bị gò bó theo cái quy
chuẩn nào cả. Ví dụ các bạn tham gia
cuộc thi, cuộc thi họ yêu cầu là đánh
đánh giá đánh giá theo cái magic này
magic kia thì các bạn cũng phải tuân thủ
theo cái đấy. Các bạn phải làm về cái bộ
rượu của người ta, đánh giá theo cách
của người ta. Nhưng mà khi mà các bạn tự
xây dựng project cá nhân ấy thì các bạn
sẽ là người quyết định mọi thứ. Các bạn
sẽ là người quyết định là các bạn được
làm về cái bài toán gì. Ví dụ như mình
mình thích các mảng compion hay mình
thích mảng NLP hay mình thích làm về
reinforcement learning thì mình sẽ làm
đúng cái bảng mà mình thích. Mình không
bị giới hạn về mặt bài toán, mình cũng
không bị giới hạn về mặt dữ liệu, mình
cũng không bị giới hạn về mặt output đầu
ra. cái sản phẩm đó ra nó như nào. Đây
là cái điều mà các cái cuộc thi sẽ không
cho các bạn. Ví dụ như mình ngày xưa
mình làm project ở đủ tất cả cái mảng để
đảm bảo sau này mình đi xin việc ở mảng
nào thì cũng được. Ví dụ mình có những
cái project về mảng computer vision. Ví
dụ computer vision thì có cả kiểu vui
vui như này.
Đây đây là một trong cái project đầu
tiên mình làm.
Cái này thì nó dựa trên một cái trò chơi
rất là thú vị của Google tên là
Quickdraw. Đây nó như thế này.
Đây mình làm hồi 2018.
Đây là công ty đầu tiên mình làm sau khi
mình ra trường này.
Đấy các bạn vẽ trước đấy nó sẽ nhận ra
là các bạn vẽ cái gì.
Đây từ này là chưa có chưa có view chưa
có vision language model đâu các bạn
nhá. Được chưa? hoặc là
như thế này.
Phiên bản capital vision thì như này
bây giờ nó ra đến yolo 12 rồi. Đây mình
là phiên bản yolo 2 rất là cũ rồi. Trong
như thế này đây. Tất nhiên bây giờ các
cái mô hình nó tốt hơn nó rất là nhiều
rồi. Bây giờ cái mô hình này mà cái này
mà up lên thì chả ai người ta để ý đâu.
Được chưa? Mình làm được rất là lâu rồi,
lâu rồi thì mới được như này. Còn là bề
bảng NLP thì mình cũng có đây. À NLP đây
cả Python cả T of Flo đây.
Đây
AP đây phân loại văn bản.
Mấy cái bộ này nó giống như cái bộ chúng
ta làm cái bộ về job ấy. Những cái bộ
này như mà đây là những cái bộ public nó
dễ hơn cái bộ của job của chúng ta. T vì
bộ này nó khá là cân bằng. Các class nó
đều cân bằng cả. Đây các bạn nhìn này.
Nó đều rất cân bằng. Nó khác với cái bộ
job. Bộ job ra nó lệch thì nó mới gần
với thực tế. Còn cái bộ này là bộ public
thì người ta đã làm sạch sẵn rồi. Được
chưa? NP ngày xưa có một thời mình thích
tìm hiểu cái bảng reinforcement learning
thì mình có mấy cái project về
reinforcement learning này đây
đây reinforce learning này đây flopy
first nhưng mà sau này mình tìm hiểu
được 2 năm mình thấy là nó cũng chả có
tác dụng không phải không có tác dụng mà
chả xin việc ở đâu được cả mình thôi
mình bỏ đấy reforce learning này học
tăng cường này
cái mảng mà mình bảo các bạn là cần xả
người ta học đấy
Đây rem learning như này được chưa? Và
cả cái project kiểu vui vui nữa. Đấy thì
các bạn cũng các bạn không cần phải làm
cái project gì nó quá là cao siêu. Các
bạn chỉm sao mà các bạn thấy là tôi làm
một cái project gì để tôi có thể chứng
minh được cái bộ kỹ năng của tôi. Ví dụ
các bạn các bạn học về web các bạn phải
chứng minh là mình có khả năng dùng CSS,
JavaScript hoặc là HTML chẳng hạn. Ví dụ
như vậy đúng không? Hoặc các bạn làm về
software các bạn có những cái project
các bạn chứng minh khả năng về software
của mình các bạn làm doer đủng các thứ
được chưa? Thế thì khi mà các bạn sử
dụng tài khoản pháp này, thứ nhất là các
bạn sẽ không bị gò bó vào một cái topic
hay là một cái gì đấy cụ thể. Các bạn
thoải mái, các bạn được phát huy cái sự
sáng tạo của các bạn. Và thứ hai nữa ấy
là những cái project c những cái project
cá nhân cá nhân này ấy nếu mà các bạn
may mắn các bạn nhận được nhiều sự tương
tác đến từ cộng đồng thì nó sẽ một cái
điểm cộng vô cùng lớn. Tại vì rõ ràng là
bây giờ trong số ông nào cũng có những
một vài cái report như này thì m ông nào
có ví dụ khoảng một vài trăm khoảng vài
trăm star chẳng hạn thì đấy sẽ cái điểm
cộng rất là lớn của các bạn.
Mà thật ra ấy kiếm star nhiều ấy th
không phải là project càng phức tạp nó
sẽ càng được càng càng càng được nhiều
star đâu. Ví dụ cái project mình nhiều
nhất là cái này 8 phải được 8300 là nó
rất là đơn giản nó chỉ khoảng 30 dòng
code thôi.
Cái này thậm chí nó thậm chí là nó nó
chả liên quan gì đến AI cả. Đây cái
project của mình đây cái project nó
không liên quan gì đến AI. Một trong số
cái project hiếm hoi mình hoàn toàn chả
liên quan gì đến AI cả. Nó chỉ đơn giản
là có ảnh đổ vào convert thành ảnh mãi
xong thế thôi chả liên quan gì đến AI.
Thế thì nếu các bạn dành ra các bạn xây
dựng một vài những cái poch cá nhân như
vậy các bạn đưa lên git hóc rồi các bạn
có thể chia sẻ làm sao để lấy được star
này thì ví dụ như mình ngày xưa ấy mình
sẽ chia sẻ những cái nền tảng như kiểu
là Reddit này hoặc là Facebook này hoặc
cả trên Linkin nữa.
Đấy thì mình chia sẻ những cái nền tảng
này cả của cả nền tảng với người Việt và
cả nước ngoài nên mình viết tất cả bằng
tiếng Anh cả để cho đảm bảo mình có thể
chia sẻ đi đâu cũng được. Đây anh này
được chưa? Thế thôi đây nó lại giúp cho
các bạn có thể làm sao các bạn mình nghĩ
đây sẽ là tại vì trong thư buổi mà bằng
cấp thì ai cũng có đúng không i thì ai
cũng có rồi cái thư buổi bây giờ việc I
là các bạn có là gần như là bây giờ gần
như quá là phổ cập rồi cái thời ngày xưa
của mình thì có thể có người có người
không bây giờ ngày xưa dân kỹ thuật của
mình có thể là nhiều bạn có chỉ có tố x
thôi nhưng mà bây giờ thì thấy là gần
như là il quá là phổ cập rồi
ok có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không
có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không
có ai có thắc mắc hay là có ai có cái gì
mà các bạn nghĩ là mình có thể giúp các
bạn được không?
Thế nhá. Thế tất cả những cái bản chit
là những cái tài liệu mà mình chia sẻ
các bạn ấy thì mình sẽ đề xuất thì khó
lắm các bạn ạ. Tại vì nó phải tùy thuộc
vào từng người thì rất là khó. Tại vì
nếu mình đề xuất thì mình thì mình sẽ
ngồi mình làm luôn sự ấy. Nếu vì mình
mình mà ngồi đề xuất mình sẽ làm luôn.
nó thuộc vào cái ý tưởng của từng người.
Bản thân mình ngày xưa mình làm cái
project này mình cũng mình cũng chả dựa
vào ai đề xuất cả. Mình thấy cái gì hay
thì mình làm. Không ai đề xuất cho mình
cái này cả. Tại vì theo mình cũng không
có ai để hỏi.
Nhưng cái project mà các bạn làm ấy, các
bạn không cần phải là người đầu tiên
nhưng các bạn làm nó có cái nét riêng
của các bạn. Các bạn làm theo cách riêng
của bạn. Ví dụ này, ví dụ cái project về
Fly Bird này.
Mình không phải người đầu tiên. Có người
người ta làm trước rồi nhưng mà có người
hướng người ta làm trên Facebook khác
người ta làm trên Facebook là thì mình
là làm là mình mình làm trên Python thế
thôi mình làm trên Python nó khác rồi
được chưa
cái về ý tưởng ví dụ ý tưởng làm project
đề án thứ là thứ thứ thường là phải dựa
vào chính chúng ta các bạn có ý tưởng
các bạn muốn làm các bạn có thể hỏi
mentor đấy nhưng mà ý tưởng thường là
phải dựa vào chúng
Các biết thử dữ cho đi hình ảnh á. Đầu
tiên thì nó sẽ có một cái đoạn là người
ta thết là nói về ảnh ấy thì nó sẽ có
hai loại ảnh. Ảnh đen trắng với ảnh màu.
Ảnh ảnh đen ảnh ảnh đen trắng thì ờ
chúng ta sẽ lưu vào một cái mảng hai
chiều còn ảnh màu lưu vào mảng ba chiều.
Thì cái việc đầu tiên là chúng ta sẽ
phải thay đổi cái thứ tự. Nhưng mà mà
cái này cái này nếu mà chỉ nói trong
khoảng 5 10 phút nó sẽ hơi khó sẽ hơi
khó. Ờ ví dụ đầu tiên các bạn phải đổi
thứ tự chiều nhá. Ví dụ là cái ảnh màu đ
ba chiều chiều cao, chiều ngang về kênh
màu thì biểu tiên kênh màu phải đẩy lên
lên đầu trước. Thì thứ hai nữa là các
cái giá trị các cái giá trị trong cái
mảng đấy nó sẽ là từ 0 đến 25. Các bạn
sẽ phải đưa về từ 0 đến 1 đấy các bạn
chuẩn hóa nó về cho con thêm một vài nh
bước nữa. Nhưng mà đấy là cái bước xử lý
cơ bản. L học sĩ hiểm như thầy th nghiên
cứu không sao em ạ.
Cái chương trình ngày xưa của anh cái
chương trình anh học ở Tic ấ nó cũng
thiên là chương trình mình nghiên cứu mà
saong anh anh ra ngoài anh đi làm mà
thật ra môi trường đại học ấy nó chỉ là
cái nó là cái nơi để chúng ta chúng ta
có một cái môi trường tức là mọi người
người ta đều học đều nghiên cứu cái gì
đấy thôi còn sau các bạn học về nghiên
cứu là các bạn đi ra làm ở công ty ngoài
là quyền của các bạn mà
cái trường universitet của mình là cái
định hướng của nó nó là định hướng
nghiên cứu chứ nhưng mà mình đi làm ở
công ty ngoài mình vẫn áp dụng bài toán
ngoài bình thường nó làm sao đâu chủ là
do mình thôi.
Và thông thường mình nghĩ là trường ranh
cao với trường ranh thấp chẳng qua là
nóc là cái đầu vào đầu vào sinh viên này
rồi có thể là một chút về cơ sở hạ tầng.
Ví dụ các bạn thấy là ở Hà Nội có trường
ngoại thương chẳng hạn ngoại thương các
bạn bảo cái đầu vào sinh viên đã giỏi
vãi cả trưởng ra rồi thì thì đúng chất
lượng đầu vào nó đã giỏi như vậy rồi thì
thì tất nhiên đầu ra nó cũng sẽ tốt thôi
đúng không? Thì nhiều khi có những
trường rank cao toàn ông giỏi vào thì tự
nhiên nó sẽ làm cho cái trường đấy lúc
nào nó cũng trong tốt. Kiểu kiểu như
vậy. Nên là cái việc mà trường nó dạy gì
nó không quá quan trọng đâu. Quan trọng
là mình thôi.
Ok. Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Có có câu hỏi gì nữa không
các bạn ơi? Đáng nhẽ [ho]
đáng nhẽ hôm nay mình dạy các bạn hai
tiếng nhưng mà thua các bạn ạ.
của mình chắc là mình
chắc là mình không
à trong một project thì phân chữ công
việc trong team nào nó còn tùy các bạn
ví dụ như nhá mình toàn làm startup đúng
không thì mình sẽ có một ông PM một ông
một ông project manager mình sẽ phân
chia công việc đúng không sẽ có người
phụ trách tiền sử dữ liệu một người phụ
trách số liệu mô hình một người phụ
trách file to mọi người phụ trách triển
khai
được chưa [hắng giọng] nó còn tùy vào qu
quy quy mô của công ty và chúng tôi phụ
cái bài bài toán là bài tập toán gì nữa
bài toán về computer computer vision nó
sẽ khác bài toán về NLP nó sẽ khác. Bài
toán về đac truyền thống nó sẽ khác nó
không có một cái pattern cố định đâu. Mà
ý tưởng vẫn là gì? Là phân chia cái bài
toán lớn thành những bài toán nhỏ. Mỗi
một người sẽ làm cái một cái task nhỏ.
Làm sao để tôi đảm bảo là tôi đảm bảo là
cái đầu ra với đầu vào sẽ được nhất
quán, sẽ được thống nhất giữa các thành
viên trước khi làm. Thế thôi.
Ok.
Có bắt nào câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Dự vào công việc á.
>> [hắng giọng]
>> mình thì mình thấy là ở Việt Nam thì nó
khá là khắc nghiệt tại vì là các cái job
các cái job đều yêu cầu là cứ phải có
hai ba năm kinh nghiệm trong khi là mới
ra trường. Mình thấy ở Đức nó nhân văn
hơn người mới ra trường người ta vẫn có
cơ hội chứ còn ở Việt Nam thì gần như là
cơ hội nó khó quá. Mình thì vẫn nghĩ là
trong vài năm tới những cái ứng dụng
kiểu LM ví dụ là kiểu Rag chatbot mà vẫn
nghĩ là nó vẫn sẽ ok. Ví dụ nhá mọi
người có bạn thấy trên mạng người ta hay
nói về Asian với AI nhưng mà thật ra ấy
các cái bên mà họ liên lạc với mình họ
muốn họ để mình làm sản phẩm cho họ ấy
hầu hết là sẽ liên quan ví dụ như con
đến làm R chatbot tức là có những con
chatbot nó có thể nó nhận cái rượu đồ
vào của mình sau nó sẽ trả lời giữa cái
dựa đấy đấy chứ còn cái về aentic AI về
Asian mọi người nói nhiều nhưng mà thực
ra thì
thật ra thì thì gọi là khi kiểu thương
mại hóa thì
mình thấy không có nhiều nhu yêu cầu
thấy nó không có nhiều hoặc là nếu có
thì ví dụ những cái flow hiện tại ví dụ
các bạn dùng N8N nó cũng khá là ok rồi
hoặc có những cái hệ thống automation
khác nó chỉ đơn giản thôi nó cũng khá là
ok rồi nhưng mà những cái thứ như kiểu
RB thì thấy là nhu cầu rất là nhiều
à mảng computer vision là cái mảng yêu
thích của mình nhưng mà thực sự là trong
3 4 năm đến đây thì nó bị lép phế hơn so
với m bảng NLP mình rất là hi vọng trong
tương lai sẽ cái mảng Cion mình nó sẽ
lấy lại được cái ánh hào quang như ngày
xưa không biết là bao giờ không biết là
bao giờ
Mình thì nghĩ là sau cái thời kỳ mà bây
giờ các cái ông lớn cứ đổ theo việc là
xây dựng cái mô hình lớn cái last lu thì
có thể trong tương lai họ sẽ bắt đầu sẽ
chuyển sang là cái small langage model
những cái mô hình kích thước nhỏ thôi.
Có thể là dưới 1 tỷ chứ là dưới nửa tỷ
tham số. Mình nghĩ là tương lai sẽ theo
cái hướng này. Cái mô hình nhỏ nhẹ làm
những cái tas cụ thể tốt thay vì là cái
gì cũng làm được.
Ok.
Mình nghĩ là mình có một cái may mắn là
là
mình à mình học và mình làm việc trong
cái thời kỳ mà AI nó chưa phát triển.
Ví dụ nhá, ví dụ cái khóa này đi. Các
bạn cứ thử nghĩ mà xem những cái buổi
thực hành đúng không? Mặc dù bây giờ
chúng ta đều hiểu là gì? Là chúng ta bao
gồm là các bạn với mình sau thực tế bây
giờ chúng ta đều code chúng ta đều dùng
AI cả đúng không? Dùng close các bạn
dùng antigravity đúng không? chúng ta
đều hiểu b chúng ta đều dùng ai để code
cả. Thế nhưng mà rõ ràng trong những cái
khóa như thế này bây giờ mà mình cái
buổi thực hành mình mà mở anti mình mở
anti gravity hoặc là mình mở close ra ấy
thì các bạn nhìn nó sẽ không hay đúng
không? Bây giờ tôi đi học cái ông thầy
ông thầy lại cũng dùng AI để code tôi
thì còn ra cái gì nữa đúng không? Thì
mình nghĩ là mình có một cái may mắn là
gì? Là mình đã có cái cơ hội để mình
tích lũy cái gọi là cái khả năng lập
trình khi mà e nó chưa phát triển.
Thế nên là mình nghĩ là khi mình nhìn
vào những cái code của AI có thể là mình
sẽ có một cái lợi thế một chút so với
những cái bạn học AI ở thời điểm hiện
nay khi mà các bạn phải dựa vào với E
quá là nhiều rồi. Mình thì những cái gì
mà những cái dự án của công ty hoặc là
của trường nó có deadline nó có thời
gian gấp thì mình vẫn dùng AI code như
bình thường.
Nhưng mà những cái project cá nhân của
mình mình không có deadline, làm được
thì làm chả làm được thì thôi. Chiu chiu
chiu thì mình vẫn tự code mình tự code
không phải là không phải vì cái gì cao
siêu. Tại vì là tại vì là mình vẫn muốn
duy trì cái bộ kỹ năng để còn đi dạy học
đúng không? Không chỉ cái lớp chúng ta
những cái lớp những cái lớp deep
learning rồi lớp LM nữa. Bây giờ bây giờ
đi dạy học các bạn mà mình cứ đi mở AI
ra code thì nó không hay đúng không? Đây
là với mình. Còn với các bạn thì mình
nghĩ là các bạn nắm được kiến thức lập
trình cơ bản.
Th m kí thức lập trình cơ bản phương
pháp cơ bản sau các bạn dùng AI code để
code thoải mái không vấn đề gì miễn làm
sao mà cái code của AI nó tạo ra ấy mà
các bạn đọc những dòng code các bạn hiểu
nó làm cái gì mà không cần phải bắt nó
giải thích hoặc là không cần phải nhìn
vào comment thế là đạt yêu cầu thế nhưng
mà trong cái thư buổi hiện nay cái việc
mà làm sao để tôi có thể tôi chịu khó
tôi tự học cái nền tảng vững chắc thay
vì việc tôi dựa vào ai từ đầu nghĩ là nó
sẽ rất là khó tại vì là người người nhà
xung quanh đều dùng ai cả bây gi chay
chay nó rất rất là ấy. Thế nhưng mà mình
vẫn nghĩ là nếu mà các bạn chịu khó cái
giai đoạn đầu một vài tháng đầu mình học
cái thứ cơ bản mình chịu khó tự code thứ
ấy thì mình nghĩ là nó sẽ tốt hơn cho nh
sau này.
Nhiều lúc code ngu lắm các bạn ạ. Nhiều
lúc đọc code nhìn nó buồn cười lắm các
bạn ạ. Cùng cái chỗ nó cùng cái chỗ khởi
tạo nó khởi trên đã khởi tạo, dưới lại
khởi tạo tiếp. Thế nhưng mà nếu mà các
bạn các bạn các bạn không có cái kỹ năng
cốt nhất định các bạn sẽ không đọc được
cái cái chỗ đấy. Đấ.
Ok.
Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì nữa không
các bạn ơi. Có lẽ hôm nay các bạn cho
các bạn lại cho mình xin phép là cho
mình lại ăn bớt của các bạn. Vậy hôm nay
buổi cuối cũng không còn buổi đảo bù hôm
nay thọ mình đau quá rồi
làm điều hòa hơi nhiều thôi coi coi như
các bạn cho mình xin phép mình ăn bớt
hai ch phút của các bạn nhá.
Lời nói cuối à mình rất là cảm ơn các
bạn đã cùng mình đồng hành cho khoa học
này phải kéo dài khoảng 2 tháng đúng
không? Thì tất nhiên là khoa học này
cũng về tất cả mọi khoa học khác buổi
cuối mình đều nói những câu tương tự
nhau. Đầu tiên thì mình vẫn phải luôn
khẳng định là dù mình có cố gắng đến mức
nào đấy nữa thì chắc chắn dung cuộc khoa
học này vẫn sẽ có những cái điểm mà nó
chưa thực sự làm hài lòng các bạn hay là
nó chưa có thực sự nó đúng như kỳ vọng
của các bạn. Cái khóa mình là cái khóa
mà mình mới add slide. Cái khóa trước
cái đấy là cái nửa đầu khóa này chúng ta
học cái slide cái nền đen ấy. Đấy là cái
slide mình mới update nhưng cái khóa
trước vẫn học theo cái slide cũ.
Ờ
tất nhiên là khó này nó vẫn có những cái
thứ nó không có hàng các bạn và mình vẫn
cố gắng làm sao để liên tục những cái
khóa sau mình sẽ cải thiện tốt hơn so
với khóa trước. Nhưng mà tất nhiên cái
điểm này nó vẫn không thể nó tránh khỏi.
Mình rất là mong các bạn thông cảm. Ờ
trong tương lai. Trong tương lai nếu mà
các bạn có bất kỳ một cái gì mà các bạn
nghĩ là mình có thể giúp đỡ, có thể
support các bạn thì các bạn cứ ới mình.
Cái group Zalo mình vẫn sẽ để nguyên tất
cả những thứ tài liệu trên YouTube trên
Driver nó sẽ còn nguyên Forever. Các bạn
muốn ch vào lúc nào cũng được. Sau này
trong tương lai có những gì các bạn muốn
hỏi mình về kiến thức, về định hướng
hoặc là các bạn các bạn nào các muốn đi
tìm hiểu du học đặc biệt là du học Đức
chẳng hạn các bạn có thể liên lạc với
mình nhá. Thì tất cả trong tương lai có
cái gì mà mình thấy các bạn thấy là mình
có thể giúp các bạn thì các bạn cứ ới
mình.
Với mình thì à
các bạn học mình
kể cả sau này các bạn không học như khóa
sau của mình thì các bạn vẫn là học viên
của mình và các bạn học viên của mình
thì bất kỳ cái gì các bạn thấy là mình
có thể giúp được. Các bạn cứ ới mình ờ
với mình thì cái khóa này nó là khóa học
về AI, về dat về machining nhưng mà với
mình thì
trong tương lai các bạn cũng không nhất
thiết các bạn phải theo cái mảng này.
Nếu các bạn thấy là mình hợp với AI thì
theo, còn không thì các bạn chuyển cái
mảng khác cũng được. Với mình quan trọng
nhất là các bạn tìm được một cái hướng
đi phù hợp và các bạn hạnh phúc với cái
hướng đi đó. Hạnh phúc đây là là gì? Các
bạn kiếm được tiền từ nó, các bạn thoải
mái với nó. Còn việc các bạn có theo yếu
ai các bạn có thành công với AI hay
không thì theo mình nó cũng không phải
là cái gì nó quá quan trọng. Bản thân
mình ngày xưa họ họ mình học Bách Khoa
cái hướng đi của mình là về mạng máy
tính, mình học về network security thế
nhưng mà sau này mình cũng đi làm về AI
mình cũng chuyển thôi. Tức là không phải
ai cũng để theo được cái mảng chọn từ
ban đầu đến mãi đúng không? cái việc
chúng ta làm trái ngành chuyện bình
thường thì nếu sau này các bạn thấy là
có một cái mảng khác các bạn thấy là nó
phù hợp với các bạn hơn thì mình cũng
rất là mong là các bạn sẽ thành công với
cái định hướng đấy. Và sẽ còn tuyệt vời
hơn nữa là nếu mà kể cả các bạn nhìn
sang những cái mảng khác nhưng mà nếu mà
những cái kiến thức mà các bạn học trong
cái khóa này mà nó giúp cho các bạn
trong quá trình các bạn làm việc các bạn
ứng dụng những cái bài toán các bạn thì
đối với mình nó không có gì tuyệt vời
hơn thì mình rất là mong là mình rất là
mong các bạn trong lớp bất kể các bạn
đang đi học và đang đi làm bất kể các
bạn vị hướng sa các bạn làm như thế nào
thì mình cũng rất là mong là các bạn sẽ
gạt thái được những thành công ờ trên
cái lị hướng mà các bạn đã chọn và mình
rất là mong là nếu sau này trong tương
lai có cơ hội có thể được gặp các bạn ở
ngoài đời. Ờ và như mình nói ờ có cái gì
mà mình giúp đỡ các bạn thì các bạn đừng
ngại các bạn nói với mình.
Ờ đây này hè mình vẫn đang dỗi trong năm
học có để hơi bận âm âm một chút. Thế
nhưng mà như mình nói rồi cái group Zalo
mình vẫn để đấy các bạn có cái gì các
bạn vẫn có thể thắc mắc mình các bạn thể
inbox mình hoặc có thể có lẽ inbox thì
ok hơn đúng không? Tại vì tránh làm
loãng cái group quá. Thế thì lần này
cuối thì mình rất là cảm ơn các bạn một
lần nữa và à
cảm ơn các bạn đồng hành cùng với mình
và mình chúc rằng các bạn sẽ gặp được
nhiều thành công trong tương lai.
Ok
đấy là những lời mình muốn nói rất là
cảm ơn các bạn.
Thế nhá kể sao các bạn không học khóa
tiếp của mình các bạn học mình một khóa
rồi thì các bạn là học viên của mình.
Cái gì mình giúp được các bạn nói mình
nhá.
Ok.
ta